ANNOUNCEMENT WE GOTTA WAIT FOR
ONE MORE MEMBER FOR CAN START --
SO THAT'S OUR LITTLE DELAY HERE
HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY MAKES HERE
SOON AS MULTIPLE COMMITTEES ARE
MEETING RIGHT ON NINE O'CLOCK SO
SOON AS WE GET ONE MORE MEMBER
GOING START.
THANKS
THANK YOU KIND SIR.
WELL GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING FOLKS.
GOOD MORNING TO OUR FIRST
MEETING OF FIRST COMMITTEE FIRST
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME EACH ONE OF
YOU HAS MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
TO THE SOMEBODY PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT COMMITTEE.
THE COMMITTEE HAS A COUPLE NEW
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL
WAS A VICE CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG.
WE ARE WORKFORCE DURING THIS FOR
THE COMING MONTHS AND AFFORD IT
WORKED WITH EACH ONE OF YOU.
AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO OFFER
VICE CHAIR ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL
AN OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE SOME
OPENING WELCOMING REMARKS AND
THERE AFTER.
ANY OTHERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
SO AT THIS.
A TIME TO REJOICE OVER GEORGE
LIKED AS A PORTS.
IN WITHOUT ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN HERE NO OTHERS WE HAVE A
COUPLE MOMENTS ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
MAKE.
MEMBERS WE DO NEED TO ADOPT THE
COMMITTEES ROLES FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION. TO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
A MOVE THE BULLS SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MISTER COOLEY SECOND BY MISTER
VOEPEL -- SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THAT'S A QUESTION OFF YOU UP
BEFORE THAT WILL NOT DO THE
RECALLS A STEP.
THE QUESTION ON THOSE RULES YES
ARE WE GONNA MOVE TO ADOPT OR
YOU DON'T ROLL CALL.
WHERE DO ROCK OFFERS?
RODRIGUEZ I PREFER HERE
[inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
CERVANTES [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
O'DONNELL HERE.
IN WITH THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM
RULES ARE ADOPTED WE HAVE
FOURTEEN ITEMS ON THE AGENDA.
HOWEVER ITEM NUMBER TEN A. B.
SIX SIX FOUR COOPER WAS POOR BY
THE AUTHOR IN ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
TWO BONTA.
THIS FOR BY THE COMMITTEE DUE TO
RECENT AMENDMENTS IMPOSSIBLE
REFERRAL.
IN WITHOUT THAT.
WOULD YOU HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
ON THE ROSES WATER DOT COM BUT
IT WOULD HAVE.
PREFERRED ON YEAH I JUST I I DO
I DO.
JUST RECEIVED THESE RULES DO
THEY HAVE A VERSION IN THERE
WHERE AND WHEN MEMBERS BRING FOR
DIVESTMENT BILLS.
THAT WOULD IDENTIFY.
WHERE THE MONEY IS GOING TO COME
FROM THAT IS NOT BET THAT IT
THAT IS NOT -- THAT IS NOT
RETURNED ON AREN'T SO IN OTHER
WORDS -- YOU KNOW WE'VE NUMBER
DIVESTMENT BILLS RIGHT.
AND THOSE MAY HARM THE RATE OF
RETURN.
OUR OUR OUR RETIREMENT FUNDS
EARNED.
DO WE HAVE STUFF POLICIES ARE
POLICY EMBEDDED IN THESE RULES
THAT SPEAK TO THAT AND WOULD.
IS REALLY WHAT WE NEED TO BE
DOING IS WE NEED TO BE VETTING
THESE.
IS DIVESTMENT BILLS MUCH.
IN A MUCH MORE COMPREHENSIVE
FASHION -- AND I I A RELEASE MY
FAMILY MEMBER SHOULD IDENTIFY
WHERE THE LOS RATE OF RETURN IS
GOING TO COME FROM WORK.
IS THERE ANYTHING IN THIS IN
THESE ROLES.
SPEAKS TO THE THE HOUSE WAS.
DID NOT HEAR THOSE BILLS A
DESIRE SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE NOT
BUT BUT I I WOULD HOPE GOING
FORWARD THAT WE WOULD
CONTEMPLATE SUCH A RULE.
OF RULE THAT WOULD CREATE A
PROCESS WHERE WE COULD TAKE A
LOOK.
AT THE DIVESTMENT BILLS IN A
MUCH MORE COMPREHENSIVE FASHION
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP
COMING AND I'LL JUST THIS JUST
MY OPINION MISTER CHAIR I'M NOT
GONNA NOW WHEN I DO NOW.
YEAH I GET THAT -- BUT I I
REALLY THINK WE OUGHT TO HAVE A
PROCESS.
AND I KNOW THE GUYS I THINK IT'S
HEALTH COMMITTEE HAS A PROCESS
FOR SOME BILLS THAT COME FORWARD.
AND MAYBE WE SHOULD CONTEMPLATE
SUCH A PROCESS INSIDE THIS
COMMITTEE WHERE IN THOSE BILLS
WOULD BE GIVEN A MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE LOOK BEFORE THEY
EVEN GET TO THE COMMITTEE OR ON
THEIR WAY OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE THESE DIVESTMENT BILLS
CAN BE VERY.
IMPACTFUL SOCIALLY FOR SURE BUT
ALSO FISCALLY TO THE HEALTH OF
OUR OF OUR OUR OUR STATE
RETIREMENT FUND STIRS IN PERSON
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
RETIREES AN OBLIGATION. TWO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS -- TO TO TO
GET A DECENT RATE OF RETURN
CERTAINLY WE SHOULD BE SOCIALLY
CONSCIOUS BUT WE SHOULD ALSO BE
FISCALLY CONSCIOUS THAT I TURN
IT BACK TO YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND CONCERNS THAT
ON THAT AS WELL THAT IS
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN TALKING
STAFF JUST RECENTLY ON THAT. FOR
FUTURE ADOPTION -- BUT IN THIS
CURRENT SET THE REGARD OPTION
THOSE ARE NOT IN THERE BUT THAT
IS SOMETHING I'M LOOKING AT
DOING FOR THE FEEDBACK.
THAT IS WELL POINT WELL TAKEN
THANK YOU.
A SUMMER COOLEY QUESTION.
WELL MORE JUST AN OBSERVATION BY
WAY OF FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
I'M ACTUALLY FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROVISION IN QUESTION.
YOUR IN BOTH THE INSURANCE CODE
AND FOR THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
IF THERE'S A BILL THAT AFFECTS
THE COST OF HEALTHCARE.
THERE IS PROVISION THOSE CABLES --
THERE IS PROVISION THOSE
COMMITTEE RULES FOR STUDIES BUT
THAT'S ACTUALLY FOUNDED UPON A
STATUTORY ACT BUT TROUBLES THE
GOVERNMENT CODE PROVISION THAT
SETS UP THE PROCESS DESIGNATE AN
ENTITY THAT DOES THAT
EXAMINATION.
SO AT THAT POINT WE'VE ALREADY
PASSED A LAW.
THAT SETS UP SAY STRUCTURE.
I I WILL SAY RATHER ON LIKE THE
HEALTH FIELD WHICH IS SO
GENERALIZED.
WE DO GET.
UNDER THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
STATE CONSTITUTION I DO THINK
ARE PENSION SYSTEMS ACTUALLY
ALEXANDER TELLS WITH THE MONEY
WOULD COME FROM BUT THEY CAN.
OPINE AS THEY ALWAYS DO ON THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THESE
DIVESTMENT THINGS.
BUT IF WE ADOPTED THAT SORT OF
THING I THINK WE NEED TO SET UP
A STATUTORY STRUCTURE.
AND HAS BEEN HELD BEGAN AND THEN
THERE WOULD JUST BE CONFORMING A
ROLE THAT STATUTE WHICH IS HOW
THE INSURANCE ON HEALTH STUFF
WORKS.
THANK YOU POINT ORTEGA'S OUGHT
TO HAVE THE BY CHERYL FOOTAGE OF
QUESTIONABLE [inaudible]
THE SENATE HEARING ON WILL GO
AHEAD AND START.
WHERE MOTION A SECOND ON THE ON
THE RULES I THINK WE GOT THE
MOTION?
SECOND.
MOTION BY THE O'DONNELL SECOND
CHECK WE GOT A MESS WITH THAT.
RULES ARE ADOPTED.
INSPECTOR CALDERON THAT AS WELL.
RODRIGUEZ I RODRIGUEZ I WILL
TELL I WILL TELL AYE CERVANTES
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE COOPER.
FONG.
FONG AYE O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I RUSSERT OPTED OF
FIVE EYES AND NO NOS WITH THAT
WE HAVE OUR FIRST -- AUTHOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST AB
[inaudible]
FIVE TWENTY NINE THE YOU KNOW
YOU CAN.
ALWAYS FIND THEM.
WHAT WOULD
?
FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER NEAR READY
BUT I CAN'T THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AB FIVE TWO NINE GIVE US A
PRACTICE OF IMPOSING ON THE SPOT
MANDATORY OVERTIME OF ANY
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN OR
PSYCHIATRIC.
TECHNICIAN ASSISTANT WORKING AT
THE STATE HOSPITAL.
CHRONIC STAFFING ISSUES AT OUR
STATE HOSPITALS HAVE SUBJECT IS
TO HAVE TO WORK MANDATORY
OVERTIME.
RESULTING IN BACK TO BACK EIGHT
OUR SHIPS.
IN IN THE END CREATING HEALTH
HAZARDS FOR PATIENTS AND STAFF.
WHEN I WAS AT SAN MARINO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR ACTOR PATTON STATE
HOSPITAL IN OUR AREA AND IN THE
SIMPLY FORTY OF DISTRICT?
I WALKED INTO AN AREA WHERE ALL
THE PATIENTS WERE AND STAFF WERE.
AND WHAT I SAW WAS A SINGLE LINE
OF PAIN AT LINE ON THE CEMENT
AND THAT WAS AGREED TO THE
PATIENTS WAS STATE ON ONE SIDE
AND STAFF ON THE OTHER.
THE SAFETY CONDITIONS THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT.
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO US AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THE AREA.
THERE WAS NO WALL NO BARRIER AND
I MAKE REFERENCE TO MY VISIT TO
PENN STATE HOSPITAL TO HIGHLIGHT
THE NEED TO PROVIDE.
EMPLOYEE SAFETY AT ALL OUR STATE
HOSPITALS.
PUTTING A STOP TO FORCED
OVERTIME ON THE PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS.
NOT ONLY STRENGTHENS EMPLOYEE
SAFETY BUT ALSO ENSURES PATIENTS
RECEIVE PROPER CARE AND
ATTENTION.
I BRING THIS UP BECAUSE ONE WEEK
AFTER I TORE PATTON STATE
HOSPITAL A PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN WAS ATTACKED AND SHE
WAS ATTACKING SHE WAS CUT.
THEIR SAFETY INVOLVED IN THESE
THINGS AS FAR AS MANDATORY
OVERTIME BECAUSE PEOPLE AND
STAFF HAVE TO BE ABLE TO BE
AWARE OF THEIR SURROUNDINGS AT
ALL TIMES.
IT'S NOT SAYING TO PUT AN END TO
OVERTIME MAKE IT MORE OF A
VOLUNTARY SO THAT PEOPLE COULD
ACTUALLY ADJUSTER LIFE SCHEDULES.
TO COMPLETE THAT OVER TIME.
WITH ME TODAY IS KOBE --
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS AND SPONSOR OF AB
FIVE TWO NINE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURZUM
KOBE PRESIDED WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC%
TECHNICIANS FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO THINK COMMITTEE STAFF FURTHER
THOROUGH AND ACCURATE ANALYSIS
OF AB -- FIVE TWENTY NINE OUR
MEMBERS ARE THE LARGEST DIRECT
LEVEL MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS IN STATE HOSPITALS
PRISONS AND DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS.
AB FIVE TWENTY NINE WOULD
PROHIBIT.
THE STATE FROM USING MANDATORY
OVERTIME ON ALL CLASSIFICATIONS
OF PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS AS A
STAFFING TOOL [inaudible]
OF AS MANY OF YOU KNOW ABOUT 92%
OF THE PATIENTS THAT ARE IN
STATE HOSPITALS ARE THERE UNDER
FRIENDS A COMMITMENT THAT MEANS.
THEY'RE EITHER NOT GUILTY BY
REASON OF INSANITY INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL WHETHER A
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR --
THEY'VE BEEN THERE -- OR BEEN
ASSIGNED TO THOSE HOSPITALS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE COMMITTED A
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT OFFENSE.
LAST YEAR AS MR ALMOST SPOKE.
ABOUT A MINUTE AGO.
OF OUR MEMBERS WAS BRUTALLY
ATTACKED WITH THE SHANK
[inaudible]
NOW.
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS ARE THE
FIRST RESPONDERS WHEN AN
INCIDENT HAPPENS.
BUT IT ACTUALLY TOOK A PATIENT.
TO TACKLE THE ASSAILANT.
AND SAVED OUR MEMBERS LIVES
THAT'S HOW DANGEROUS THESE
FACILITIES ARE.
THAT REALLY UNDERLINES THE NEED
TO BE ALERT AND AWARE WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE JOB.
AND WORKING AT THE BACK TO BACK
SIXTEEN HOUR SHIFTS WHEN YOU
HAVE NOT.
HAD ENOUGH SLEEP HAD NOT
PREPARED ENOUGH FOOD
[inaudible]
HAD NOT.
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
ENOUGH BREAKS TO BE RESTED.
LAST YEAR THERE WAS TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED ASSAULTS ON STAFF.
WE ONLY HAVE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS IN STATE HOSPITALS.
IT'S SO IT'S REALLY NOT A MATTER
OF IF YOU GET THE SALTED IT'S A
MATTER OF WHEN YOU GET ASSAULTED
[inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL [inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY.
NURSING THE PROFESSION OF
NURSING IS A FEMALE DOMINATED
INDUSTRY.
AND ABOUT 6265% OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP.
ARE WOMEN.
AND ABOUT 15% OF THAT 60%.
ARE SINGLE MOMS SO.
WHEN YOU HAVE?
A PRIMARY CARE GIVER LIKE A
SINGLE MOM TO A CHILD.
YOU'VE NOW IMPACTED THEM.
MORE SO THAN ANYONE ELSE BECAUSE
TRYING TO GET.
TRYING TO GET CHILD CARE ARRANGE
TRYING TO FIND SOMEBODY -- TO
PICK UP THAT CHILD AFTER SCHOOL.
WHEN YOU'VE BEEN TAPPED ON THE
SHOULDER TO WORK A SIXTEEN HOUR
DAY?
JUST MINUTES BEFORE.
HIM YOU'RE GETTING READY TO WALK
OUT THE GATE.
THAT IS INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT.
AND IF YOU ARE.
GETTING READY TO WALK OUT AND
YOU SAY NO I HAVE TO GO PICK UP
MY CHILD.
THEN YOU FACE AN ADVERSE ACTION
[inaudible]
SO.
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN DID A REPORT.
THAT RECOMMENDED TO THE
LEGISLATURE [inaudible] TO
DECREASE.
THE AMOUNT OF MAN ERIC TO
DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF OVERTIME
BY 50% -- OF THE TWENTY FOURTEEN
TWENTY FIFTEEN NUMBERS.
BY THE YEAR.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND TO ELIMINATE
THE USE OF MANDATORY OVERTIME.
IN ALL CIRCUMSTANCES EXCEPT OF
EMERGENCIES.
THANKFULLY THISYEAR IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS ISSUED.
IT PROPOSES. THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE NEW PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN POSITIONS TO BE
TRANSITIONED OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD.
WITH AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FOUR PERMANENT
INTERMITTENT POSITIONS TO HELP
PRODUCE OVER TIME.
THIS INVESTMENT INTO OUR STATE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM WILL VIRTUALLY
ELIMINATE ALL MANDATORY OVERTIME.
IN STATE HOSPITALS AND IMPLEMENT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
THAT THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION SUGGESTED -- WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COOPER.
COOLEY O'DONNELL. FOR SUPPORTING
THIS BILL LAST TIME -- WHEN IT
CAME BEFORE YOU IN? TWENTY
SIXTEEN IS SB SEVEN EIGHTY SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES FOR BEING A
JOINT AUTHOR.
AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE --
TAPPED STATE PRESIDENT ERIC SOTO.
WHEN OTHER PERSONAL COMMENTS?
GOOD MORNING -- WITHIN PLEASURE
AND HONOR TO ADDRESS YOU GUYS
HERE TODAY -- AS KOBE STATED MY
NAME IS ERIC SOTO.
I AM THE STATE PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS.
I AM A LICENSE LIKE TECH AND I
HAVE DEDICATED OVER TWENTY YEARS --
TUESDAY TO CALIFORNIA'S
DEPARTMENTS THE HOSPITAL'S.
SPECIFICALLY THE METROPOLITAN
STATE HOSPITAL IN NORWALK.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK TO THE
NECESSITY OF ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
TWENTY NINE AND THE NEED TO END
THE PRACTICE OF FORCED MANDATORY
OVERTIME FOR THOSE OF MY
PROFESSION.
AS KOBE STATED WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY SIX THOUSAND PSYCH
TEXAN RELATED CLASSIFICATIONS
WORKING FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE PROVIDE CARE TREATMENT.
MEDICATION AND THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
SEVERE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AND THOSE WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS.
WE WORK IN DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
STATE HOSPITALS.
AND IN OUR STATE'S PRISONS.
I CAN CERTAINLY ASSURE YOU THAT
SITE TAX.
DO NOT GET IN THIS PROFESSION
WITH THE HOPE OF EXTRAVAGANT PAY
AND RICHES.
AND THOSE ENTERING A PROFESSION
ALL UNDERSTAND THAT OUR JOB AS
INHERENT RISKS.
AND DANGERS ASSOCIATED
ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
HOWEVER WE ARE PROUD.
OF THE SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE.
IN WE HOPE THAT OUR EMPLOYER THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES
EVERYTHING THEY CAN. TO MINIMIZE
THE DANGERS ASSOCIATED WITH
CARRYING OUT OUR DUTIES.
AND ONE OF THE MOST PREVALENT
AND WIDESPREAD DANGERS IS
MANDATORY OVERTIME.
I WOULD.
LIKE TO ASK YOU GUYS TO PLEASE
TRY TO IMAGINE GOING TO WORK.
IN A SETTING WITH A HIGH
LIKELIHOOD THAT YOU COULD BE HIT.
SPENT ON PUNCHED KICKED BEATEN.
OR EVEN KILLED.
WHEN YOU WORK IN THESE
CONDITIONS YOU HAVE TO BE AWAKE
AND ALERT FOR YOUR ENTIRE SHIFT?
READY TO RESPOND IN A CRISIS.
IN ALL THE WHILE PROVIDING
QUALITY CARE TO THOSE PATIENTS
THAT ARE IN YOUR CHARGE.
MANY TIMES AT THE END OF YOUR
SHIFT.
YOUR BACK IS ACHING YOUR
SHOULDERS ARE TENSE.
FROM THE CONSTANT AND NEVER
ENDING NEED. TO CONSTANTLY LOOK
BEHIND YOU. FIVE MINUTES BEFORE
YOUR SHIP DANS.
YOU CAN GET A PHONE CALL TELLING
YOU YOU CAN'T GO HOME.
YOUR MANDATE IT TO WORK.
YOU'RE STUCK FOR ANOTHER EIGHT
HOURS.
WHEN SPIKE TECHS GET THIS CALL
BECAUSE OFTEN THROW OUR LIVES
AND THE LIVES OF OUR LOVED ONES
INTO DISARRAY?
PARENTS HAVE TO SCRAMBLE TO
TRYING TO ARRANGE FOR THE
CHILDREN TO GET PICKED UP FROM
SCHOOL.
OR TO FIND CHILDCARE OFTEN AT
THE LAST MINUTE.
I HAVE PERSONALLY WITNESSED.
FELLOWS LIKE TEXAN TEARS.
BECAUSE SHE COULDN'T ARRANGE OR
FIND SOMEONE TO PICK UP HER
CHILD.
OUR MEMBERS ARE SOMETIMES FACED
WITH THE AWFUL CHOICE.
DO I STAY AT WORK ASK ORDERED
AND LEAVE MY CHILD UNATTENDED.
WHERE DO I GO AND ATTEND TO MY
CHILD?
AND THEREBY RISKING POSSIBLE
DISCIPLINE.
I CAN SPEAK FROM FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE.
MY BROTHERS AND DIRE SECOND
GENERATION PSYCHICS.
OUR MOTHER WAS A SENIOR PSYCH
TECH WHO WORKED AN OPTION WHICH
IS ELEVEN PM AT NIGHT TO SEVEN
IN THE MORNING. TOO MANY TIMES
SHE WOULD CALL US UP IN THE
MORNING TO TELL US THAT SHE WAS
MANDATE IT.
AND THAT WE ALL HAVE TO FIND A
WAY AND WALK TO SCHOOL.
I COULD TELL YOU HOW MANY
BIRTHDAYS AND HOLIDAYS WERE
SPENT WITHOUT HER BECAUSE OF THE
PRACTICE OF MANDATORY OVERTIME.
TO THIS DAY THIS PRACTICE
CONTINUES.
AND THE CHILDREN OF SOME OF THE
MOST DEDICATED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
ARE MISSING OUT IN GROWING UP
WITH THEIR FAMILIES PRESENT FOR
SOME MAJOR EVENTS OF THEIR LIVES.
IF THAT WASN'T ENOUGH.
THE STATE IN SIMPLE TERMS.
FORCED MANDATORY OVERTIME IS NOT
SAFE.
STAFF ARE EXPECTED TO BE ALERT
AT ALL TIMES.
WHEN THE SLIGHTEST LAPS AND
OBSERVATION COULD LEAD TO TRAGIC
CONSEQUENCES?
MANDATORY OVERTIME FLATLY MEANS
UNSAFE WORKING CONDITIONS.
WE ARE MANDATED TO COVER STAFF
SHORTAGES.
STAFF GET EXHAUSTED AND GET
BURNED OUT.
THIS LEAVES THE STAFF BEING LESS
ALERT.
THIS ALSO MEANS A HIGHER
LIKELIHOOD OF STAFF INJURIES.
WHICH CAN ALSO AGAIN LEAD TO
STAFF BECOMING SO EXHAUSTED.
THAT MANY OF THEM CALL IN JUST
TO AVOID BEING MANDATED.
WHICH OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN SEE IS
GONNA SELL PERPETUATE THAT CYCLE.
MY FELLOW PSYCH TECHS ENTERED
INTO STATE SERVICE BECAUSE WE
WANTED TO CONTRIBUTE TO THIS
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE WANTED TO PROVIDE A VITAL
SERVICE TO A POPULATION.
THAT IS OFTEN MARGINALIZED AND
STIGMATIZED.
HELP CALIFORNIA'S LIKE TAX
PROVIDE QUALITY CARE.
HELPS CALIFORNIA'S PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS ENJOY A SAFER
WORKPLACE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE.
WITH THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRIAN NELSON --
REPRESENT THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES SIDE PLEASED
TO BE HERE STRONG SUPPORTER THIS
VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION --
PROTECT BUT THE SISSON STATE
HOSPITALS AND A STATE FACILITY.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS RANCHO
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION FORCED OVERTIME
THREATENS THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF ALL THOSE ASSIGNED TO
MAINTAIN THE SECURITY OF THESE
FACILITIES.
MEMBERS OF THE ARE SAY ARE PROUD
TO SUPPORT OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS WHO WORK OUR STATE
HOSPITALS AND WE SUPPORT AB FIVE
TWO NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ADRIN MOHAMMED WITH THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEN IN HEARING ON ANY QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SOME REMOTE ONE ON ONE THANK YOU
MISTER SOTO -- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION VERY THOROUGH
NEARLY TOLD THE HUMAN SIDE.
OF THE IMPACT OF THIS THIS THIS --
CHALLENGE SO THE ANSWER SO THE
ANSWER TO THIS PROBLEM IS REALLY
TO HIRE MORE PSYCH TAX CORRECT
AND YOU SAID OR ARE THEY IN THIS
ARE THEY IN.
TALKING ABOUT THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET YOU KNOW BETTER
THAN I DO AT THIS POINT YEAH SO.
IT IN GOVERNOR SOME FOR PROPOSED
BUDGET OUT OF JANUARY.
THE BUDGET INCLUDED OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD IN IMPLEMENTATION OF
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
NEWS PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN
POSITIONS.
THEN THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
IMMEDIATE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOUR PERMANENT INTERMITTENT
POSITIONS USED TO BE -- USED FOR
JUST PURELY OVERTIME PURPOSES SO
YOU HAVE A TOTAL OF ROUGHLY FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY OVER THE
COURSE OF THREE YEARS NEW
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN POSITIONS.
THAT WILL VIRTUALLY ELIMINATE
ALL OF THE MANDATORY OVERTIME.
ONE THING I DIDN'T POINT OUT WAS
THIS PRACTICE OF MANDATORY
OVERTIME IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
HAS BEEN BANNED SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ONE AND SO I THINK
IT'S ONLY FAIR THAT -- WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF EQUITY -- IN THE
STATE PRACTICES AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BY SURE GOING [inaudible]
QUESTION.
HOW COME YOU HAVEN'T?
ACHIEVE THIS AND COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION I'M
TIRED.
SO THIS BILL AS THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT -- WE HAVE PROVISIONS
IN OUR CONTRACT THAT STATES HOW
MANY TIMES WE CAN BE MANDATED A
MONTH.
SO THE LAST TIME WE RAN THIS
BILL -- IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO BE A CONTRACT YEAR --
WE WERE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE DOWN
FROM SIX TIMES A MONTH.
DOWN TO FIVE TIMES A MONTH.
AGAIN FIVE TIMES A MONTH IS A
BIT TOO MUCH I THINK WHEN THE
PRACTICE IN.
AN OF ITSELF IS.
JUST A POOR PRACTICE IT
[inaudible]
I WE'VE TRIED TO GET MORE
LEVERAGE IN MORE TRACTION IN
NEGOTIATING IT IN OUR CONTRACT
BUT EACH TIME WE'VE TRIED.
WE'VE.
MOVEMENT VERY LITTLE MOVEMENT
AND COMPLETE RESISTANCE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION THEN WHEN WE
TRIED TO RUN A BILL THE BILL GOT
VETO.
SO WE'RE UP AGAINST THE WALL NOW
WE HAVE A NEW ADMINISTRATION WE
HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION THAT'S
WILLING TO INVEST INTO OUR STATE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM. TO TRYING TO
REMOVE -- THE AMOUNTS OF
MANDATORY OVERTIME AND OVER TIME
IN GENERAL.
WE REALLY THINK THAT THIS IS THE
RIGHT PATH BECAUSE IN PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS WE HAVE NOT SEEN
ANY MOVEMENT AND THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
DECADES.
OKAY I'M.
I CERTAINLY SEE THE NEED FOR
THIS.
BUT I HAVE TROUBLE CIRCUMVENT IN
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS SO.
JUST LOOKING AT IT FROM A
MANAGEMENT VIEWPOINT WHICH IS.
MY WHOLE WORLD.
I WOULD HAVE TROUBLE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL.
BUT I UNDERSTAND EXACTLY.
THE NEED [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
THANK IN IN IN APPRECIATE THOSE
THOSE COMMENTS ARE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BUT IN THE MEANTIME GOING
FROM.
THE SIX MANDATORY OVERTIME IS
TWO TWO FIVE THEY'RE STILL LIVES
ARE BEING JEOPARDIZED -- BEING
TO SEE THE THE FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE OF VISIT IN THAT AREA
AND SEEN A PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIAN A WEEK LATER BE
ATTACKED SO SEVERELY -- BRINGS
UP QUESTION INTO THE SAFETY OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS THE
STAFF THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS.
OKAY SO WITH THAT SAID.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SECOND MOTION SECOND WAS COULD I
THINK SOMEONE WANTED TO ADD
SOMETHING ON HIM TO A GOING AT
ONE QUICK ONE COMMENT.
YES RECORD I MEAN I JUST ALSO
WANT TO SEE THE NEED FOR
ELIMINATING MANDATORY OVERTIME
IN GENERAL EVEN.
IN THE WORLD WE LIVE IN WITH
HOUSING BECAUSE WHAT THEY ARE WE
FIND THAT WE HAVE MANY MEMBERS
ALL OVER THE STATE.
HAVING TO DRIVE HOURS JUST TO
THEIR PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT.
SO WHEN YOU MANDATE SOMEBODY TO
WORK THEY WORK SIXTEEN HOURS.
THE UP THE DRIVE TWO HOURS HOME.
TRY TO GET SOME SLEEP MAKE THAT
TWO HOUR DRIVE BACK TO WORK.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
AND I CAN CERTAINLY TELL YOU
I'VE HAD PERSONAL EXPERIENCES.
OF FALLING ASLEEP AT AT THE
WHEEL DRIVING HOME AFTER
OVERTIME SHIFTS SO.
AGAIN I I'D DIE UP IS STRONG SAY
THAT I'VE I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THERE SHOULD BE ANY MANDATORY
OVERTIME.
THANK YOU WITH THAT SAID --
SOMEONE LIKE GO IN CLOSE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT SAID YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S VERY INTERESTING
CONVERSATION HAVE REGARDING
MANDATORY FORCED OVERTIME.
A KIND OF A PERSONAL REFLECTION
BACK TO ME WORKING I'M WAS ENTRY
FOR ALL THESE YEARS WE TALK
ABOUT AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT HOUR
SHIFT.
WE'RE JUST THINK ABOUT IT
THERE'S MANY TIMES BACK WHEN I
WORKED MANY YEARS IN THE
INDUSTRY.
THAT I WAS FORCED TO WORK TWENTY
FOUR HOURS IMAGINE WORKING
SEVENTY TWO HOURS STRAIGHT
BECAUSE ONE SHIFT I WOULD WORK
MY RIVER TWENTY FOUR HOUR SHIFT.
THE SECOND DAY WOULD BE MY DAY
OFF BECAUSE THE THIRD IT WOULD
WORK.
BUT THERE MANY TIMES THAT I WAS
FORCED TO WORK THAT SECOND DAY
SO SEVENTY TWO HOURS STRAIGHT
WITHOUT NO REST.
NO BREAK SO TO SPEAK AND COSTLY
WORKING TIME AND TIME AGAIN SO I
SEE THE NEED FOR THIS TYPE OF
BILL.
AND WHAT IT DOES TO THIS
EMPLOYEES DOING THEIR JOB
PROTECTING THEMSELVES AND
PROVIDING CARE FOR THOSE OF THE
PATIENTS SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT.
I FULLY SUPPORT AND I COULD HAVE
A PERSONAL REFERENCE ON HOW IT
AFFECTED MY LIFE IN.
IN EVERYTHING I'VE DONE YOU KNOW
WITH OUR FAMILY LIKE YOU TALKED
ABOUT TRYING TO GET FAMILY CARE
FOR YOUR CHILDREN AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU'RE
FORCED TO WORK WHETHER IT'S THE
EIGHT HOURS IN MY CASE TWENTY
FOUR HOURS SO I DO HAVE AN IRAQ
ON THIS.
SO I THINK WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND SO WITH THAT SECTOR
LIKE TO KALRA.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO TO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ.
AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL
RESPECTFULLY ABSTAIN
[inaudible]
CERVANTES HI.
CERVANTES I COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
FONG.
O'DONNELL RIGHT O'DONNELL I SO
THE BILL NEEDS FORGET WE HAVE
THREE WILL GO AHEAD AND KEEP IN
THE ROLE.
THANK YOU FOR ON CALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU COMMITTEE.
OKAY.
SO THAT WE HAVE OUR NEXT THE
AUTHOR IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
THOUGHT I SEEN HIM.
OR SANTIAGO LIKE YOU ON IT.
SO WE HAVE -- ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
SANTIAGO AB.
EIGHT NINETY FOUR WITH THE KERRY
SHOULD IF I WAS BRIEF.
IF YOU LIKE.
THANK YOU.
AB EIGHT NINETY FOUR WOULD
INCREASE YOUR GENERAL'S EXEMPT
POSITIONS -- WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
WITHIN THE SAME EMPLOYEE PULL IN
EXISTING BUDGET I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I VOTE AND HAVE WITH
THIS ONE WITNESS MISTER CHAIR.
GOING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S CERRADO AT
THE HEAD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY JOBBERS UP
THE SERRA -- HIS PROUD TO
SPONSOR THE TIME AB EIGHT NINE
FOUR AND THANKS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO FOR AUTHORING AT THIS
BILL AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES FOR BEING A JOINT
AUTHOR.
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE THE A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT JUSTICE
WITH INCREASED FLEXIBILITY TO
MANAGE IT IT'S EXECUTIVE
PERSONNEL.
AND OPERATIONS IT WOULD ALSO
ENSURE THAT THE AG CAN MAINTAIN
A STRONGER BUS EXECUTIVE TEAM
AND OPERATIONS THAT CAN TACKLE
THE DIVERSE RESPONSIBILITIES.
OF OUR STATE'S CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND LEGAL AGENCY WITH THAT AS
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
I HAVE A MOTION A SECOND AND
WITH THAT ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
THE QUESTION BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEEN HEARING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE RESPECT AND THAT'S WHEN
I BOUGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANKS
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FOR TO US
AS I ALSO AGREED THAT THERE ARE
A CURRENT TWENTY GENERAL NEEDS
MORE RESOURCES TO HELP -- WITH --
THE WORKLOAD I THE HOUSE SO I
DO HAVE AN AYE RECOMMENDATION ON
THIS.
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
SO SECRETARY LIKE TO CALL THE
ROLL.
YEAH WE HAVE A MOTION SIR.
THE LOOK SKEWS ME THEM THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ AYE
RODRIGUEZ HI VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY COOPER FONG
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I WE'LL KEEP THAT OUR
ROLE OPEN WE HAVE AN UNCLE WE
NEED ONE MORE THANK YOU.
SO WHAT THAT WILL GO HEAD TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA ITEM
NUMBER FOUR A. B..
THREE FOURTEEN MORNING MR CHAIR
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS ANKH
MORNING STAFF.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB THREE ONE FOUR AND
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU AND YOUR
STAFF HAVE PUT INTO THE MEASURE
MISTER CHAIR.
AB THREE ONE FOUR WITH EXPANDED
UNIFORMLY APPLY REASONABLE TIME
OFF WITHOUT LOSS OF COMPENSATION
TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES IN SHORT
PROVIDES.
UNIFORMITY AND SPECIFICITY
THAT'S NEEDED IN RELEASE TIME
FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
UNDER EXISTING LAW PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS ARE REQUIRED TO ALLOW
EMPLOYEE REPRESENTATIVES
REASONABLE TIME OFF WITHOUT LOSS
OF COMPENSATION IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE IN ACTIVITIES.
RELATED TO EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS SUCH AS COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IN MATTERS BEFORE.
PERSONAL COMMISSIONS THIS IS
REFERRED TO AS RELEASE TIME.
IN PREVIOUS YEARS THERE'VE BEEN
A GROWING NUMBER OF ATTACKS ON
WORKERS RIGHTS IN ORDER TO
THWART.
THEIR ABILITY TO ENGAGE IN
COLLECTIVE POWER ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA HAS A POLICY OF
PROVIDING REASONABLE TIME OFF
WITHOUT LOSS OF PAY TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES THE LOCK.
IS AND HAS BEEN INEFFECTIVE IN
ALLOWING EMPLOYEES TO
MEANINGFULLY PARTICIPATE IN
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
BECAUSE CURRENT LAW.
IS INCONSISTENT ACROSS DIFFERENT
SECTORS OF EMPLOYMENT.
IN ORDER FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES TO
BENEFIT FROM THEIR RIGHTS TO
REPRESENTATION THEY NEED TO BE
CERTAIN OF THEIR PAID TIME OFF
ALLOWANCES.
AND BOTH EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
BENEFIT.
WHEN WORKERS PARTICIPATE IN
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS TO
ADDRESS AND RESOLVE DISPUTES AND
FACILITATE HARMONIOUS LABOR
MANAGEMENT RELATIONS AB THREE
ONE FOUR WOULD LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD?
BETWEEN EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
IT WOULD CREATE UNIFORMITY
ACROSS ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC SECTOR LABOR RELATIONS
LAWS BY GRANTING ALL PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES EQUAL RIGHTS TO
REASONABLE PAID TIME OFF. TO
ENGAGE AND SPECIFIED ACTIVITIES.
NOW MORE THAN EVER CALIFORNIA
SHOULD TAKE THE APPROPRIATE
STEPS TO ENSURE THAT OUR WORKERS
ARE EMPOWERED AND HAVE VOICES IN
THEIR EMPLOYMENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I WITH ME MITCHELL CASTRO
REPRESENTING S. YEAH YOU THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL START.
GOOD MORNING SHALL CAST OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION -- AS MR BONTA SAID THIS
IS A SIMPLE MEASURE BUILDING OFF
OF EXISTING LAW -- WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW IS IT EXISTING
LAW FORTY EMPLOYER. TO USE AS
MUCH TIME AND RESOURCES FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER
RELATIONS THEY CAN ASSIGN AS
MANY STAFF FOR UNLIMITED AMOUNTS
OF TIME TO MAKE SURE THE
POSITION IS REPRESENTED.
THEY CAN HIRE AS MANY OUTSIDE
LAW FIRMS AND CONSULTANTS AS
THEY WANT BUT CONVERSELY THE
TIME FOR EMPLOYEES TO
PARTICIPATE.
WITH PAY IS VERY VERY LIMITED --
CALIFORNIA HAS A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING STATUTES AND EACH OF
THOSE PROVIDE DIFFERENT LEVELS
OF RELEASE TIME SOME SAY COULD
PARTICIPATE IN THE FORMAL
BARGAINING PROCESS.
ONCE SAID YOU CAN GO BEFORE PER
IN A CIVIL SERVICE COMMISSION
ANOTHER SAYS YOU CAN PARTICIPATE
THE GRIEVANCE PROCESS BUT IT'S
NOT EQUAL AND IT'S VERY LIMITED --
SO FOR EMPLOYEES TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE BARGAINING PROCESS THEY
NEED TO HAVE TIME OFF WITH PAY
SO THAT THEY CAN.
HAVE THEIR POSITION REPRESENTED --
THE EMPLOYER'S GONNA THE IMPORT
OPPOSITION IS GOING TO COME UP
AND SAY THAT THIS BILL A RHODES
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
BUT WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
IS THAT RELEASE TIME IS A
PRODUCT OF THE STATUTE IT IS NOT
A PRODUCT OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING WHAT IS COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED.
IS WHAT DOES A REASONABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME OFF IN A REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME AND REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF EMPLOYEES ME.
SO THE STATUTE HAS ALWAYS
DICTATED WHAT TYPES OF ACTIVITY
CAN BE GIVEN FOR RELEASE TIME.
AND THAT IT'S FOR REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME SO THIS BILL IN
NO WAY UNDERMINES THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING.
PROCESS AT ALL.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT SOME EMPLOYERS
HAVE.
GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
STATUTE WHICH WE APPRECIATE AND
HOW IN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS -- AGREE TO
ADDITIONAL AMOUNTS TO RELEASE
TIME BUT FOR THE EMPLOYEES TO
GET THAT THEY HAVE TO GIVE
SOMETHING ELSE UP OF THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TABLE.
AND WE JUST DON'T THINK THAT'S
VERY FAIR AGAIN THIS BILL DOES
NOT NECESSARILY PUT THE
EMPLOYEES ON PAR WITH THE
EMPLOYER IT JUST SAYS.
THE EMPLOYER MUST GIVE THEM A
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME OFF TO
A REASONABLE AMOUNT OF EMPLOYEE
FOR ONLY SPECIFIED PURPOSES WE
HAVE THREE EITHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHAI
SURPRISES BUT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION I
WOULD ONLY EMPHASIZED ON THE
FACT THAT THIS IS UNIFORMITY IF
YOU LOOK AT THE BILL ITSELF
YOU'LL SEE THAT.
ALL THE DIFFERENT SECTIONS THAT
ALREADY ESTABLISHED RELEASED I'M
RIGHT.
PROVIDING REASONABLE TIME TO
DEPLOY IS THERE IN EXISTING LAW
IS BEING RE CASTED AND WILK
CAPTURING ALL THE CLARITY THAT'S
NECESSARY SO THE EMPLOYEES CAN
REPRESENT HIMSELF. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE CHOI AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT.
WITH THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BY NELSON ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
ARE I WON'T -- REHASH APPOINT
EVER MADE I THINK THEY WERE
INCREDIBLY -- SALIENT POINTS I'D
JUST LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR THE VERY
COMPREHENSIVE ANALYSIS AND SHE
COMMITTEE -- TO PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS PURPORTED PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
WHAT MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS?
GIVE ME SAID BRAMBLE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION -- I THINK
AS WITH STATED YOU KNOW THIS IS
A A SIMPLE BILL ABOUT UNIFORMITY
ABOUT CLARITY ABOUT PARITY --
CERTAINLY REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA
VALUES WE WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
MR MEMBERS MIKE WE'LL WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
STRONG SUPPORT.
MATT CRIMMINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION MACHINISTS AND I.
F. E. LOCAL TWENTY ONE SPORT.
RAIN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
ON YOUR CAR BEING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE.
PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
GOING WHEN YOU'RE A CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DEALING
GIVEN FOR THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
ON THIS BILL.
IN PARTICULAR WE ARE LOOKING TO
HAVE THE ITEM RELATED TO TIME
OFF FOR EMPLOYEE ORIENTATIONS --
REMOVED FROM THE BILL THIS WAS A
TOPIC THAT WAS.
DEBATED GREATLY AND NEGOTIATED
AS PART OF THE EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION.
LANGUAGE THAT WAS PART OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUDGET. FOR TWO
AND A HALF YEARS -- PUBLICATIONS
HE SAT DOWN WITH THE UNIONS TO
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH -- WHAT
THE EMPLOYEE ORIENTATIONS WOULD
LOOK LIKE AN ULTIMATELY WE WERE
ABLE TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
BECAUSE OF AN AGREEMENT WE CAME?
TO ON ON THAT LANGUAGE ONE OF
THE VERY SPECIFIC PROVISIONS OF
THAT LANGUAGE FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING WAS THE EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATIONS -- THAT IT WOULD
NOT HAVE PAID LEAVE TIME -- FOR
UNION EMPLOYEES TO DO THIS WORK
AND THAT IT COULD BE LEFT TO
NEGOTIATION AND PART OF THE M.
O. U. PROCESS AND THE REASON.
WAS BECAUSE ORIENTATIONS VERY SO
GREATLY AT DIFFERENT PUBLIC
AGENCIES WITH THE WITH OVER TWO
THOUSAND SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
RANGING SIGNIFICANTLY IN SIZE --
SOME AGENCIES HAVE ORIENTATIONS
ONCE A YEAR FOR NEW EMPLOYEES
WHICH CASE IT'S NOT A PROBLEM TO
TO ALLOW FOR FOR PAID LEAVE FOR
THAT EMPLOYEE.
HOWEVER OF SOME OF OUR OTHER --
DISTRICTS HAVE -- ORIENTATIONS
EVERY WEEK A HALF AN HOUR OR
THEY HAVE MULTIPLE ORIENTATIONS
A WEEK.
AS WE WOULD END UP WITH HIM WHO
HE IS THERE A BETTER TAKING
HOURS OFF EVERY WEEK -- TO BE --
TO PARTICIPATE NEEDS
ORIENTATIONS THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY WHY IT WAS LEFT OUT
OF THE ORIENTATION LANGUAGE THE
THERE WAS A ADOPTED IN THE
BUDGET.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS LANGUAGE
GOES BACK ON WHAT WAS AGREED TO
AND WHAT WAS PUT IN THE THE
BUDGET FOR THOSE REASONS --
WE'RE SEEKING FOR THAT PROVISION
TO BE REMOVED FROM THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING YOUR MEMBERS TING
HUTCHINGS ITALY CALIFORNIA
CITIES -- MY LINE MY COMMENTS
WITH MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION --
WE DO BELIEVE THAT IT DOESN'T
AND IMPACTED THE BARGAINING
PROCESS AS YOU SURF THE
BARGAINING PROCESS I'M YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU TO WEEK WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT -- YOU KNOW ONE SIZE FITS
ALL PURCHASE DON'T REALLY APPLY --
AT LEAST FROM A CITY PERSPECTIVE
WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANY COMPLAINTS --
BUT NOT HEARD ANY COMPLAINTS --
Và -- SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHEN THIS LAW WAS
ENACTED SPECIFIC TO THE
ORIENTATION PIECE.
OF FOLKS ARE ABLE TO SIT DOWN
CARE **** -- LOCALLY -- AS FAR
AS TIME PLACE MANNER -- AND
RELEASE TIME -- WITH YOU TO WHAT
WE SEE TIME AND TIME AGAIN WHEN
WE HAVE THESE ISSUES WITH
REGARDS COLLECTIVE BARGAINING --
THAT IF WE CAN IF IF THE LOCAL
UNION IS NOT SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING WHAT THEY WHAT THEY NEED
THEY THEY TALK TO THEIR FOLKS
THE STATE UNION CENTER SABELLA
TAKES OFF THE BARGAINING TABLE
IS ARE ALL THINGS THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT.
THE LEAGUE IS VERY VERY PRO.
LOCAL BARGAINING WE WANT YOU
WOULD NEGOTIATE HAVE THESE
DIALOGUES ARE LOCAL UNIONS -- WE
DO BELIEVE THAT THIS DOES -- YOU
SIR THE PARKING PROCESS THANK
YOU.
FAIR ABOUT HIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS REPRESENTING
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND SCHOOL
BUSINESS LEADERS AND THE CATER
TALL.
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE WORLD OUR
CONCERN IS THAT AB THREE
FOURTEEN WOULD PLACE AN ATTIC
CONSTRAIN ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN COUNTY OFFICES TO RE DIRECT
RESOURCES. TO SECURE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING SUBSTITUTES TO COVER
FOR THESE ADDITIONAL RELEASED
TIMES ALL THE WHILE WHILE
PROVIDING FOR COMPENSATION TO
EMPLOYEES TAKING THE ADDITIONAL
RELEASE TIME AND THEN THAT NEEDS
TO BE RECOGNIZED IN THIS WORLD
THAT.
IN EDUCATION WE CANNOT RAISE OUR
OWN REVENUES WE'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO CHARGE FEES FOR OUR SERVICES
AND SO WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE THE RIGHT LEVEL OF SUPPORT
IN STAFFING.
WHEN OUR STUDENTS ARE AVAILABLE
AND AND THEY ARE TO LEARN SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AGAIN WE
ARE RESPECTING THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS THAT WE'RE
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
LOCALLY TO ENSURE THAT EACH
SCHOOL DISTRICT COUNTY OFFICE?
HOUSE THEN THE RIGHT SUPPORT AND
STOPPING TO SECURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE FIRST SERVED AND
THEIR NEEDS ARE MET.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION THIS MEASURE CHAMBER
OF UPS RIGHT AT YOUR BAD ONE ONE
MORE COMMENT THAT I LEFT OUT --
WE WE'RE ALSO IS SEEKING
CLARIFICATION ON THE TIME FOR
PREPARATION OF ACTIVITIES -- BUT
NOT NOT SAYING THAT THAT THAT
SHOULDN'T BE ALLOWED JUST
LOOKING FOR CLARITY ON WHAT THAT
MEANS IN A IN A LOOK TO WORK
WITH THE THE AUTHOR THE SPONSOR
ON ON WHAT THAT MIGHT BE.
OKAY THANK YOU HAVE ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION IN BREAKING WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS ALSO OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED READ A LINE OR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE.
WITH THE SCA IN THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. TO SAY NONE
OF THE OTHER LIKE TO CLOSE.
WHAT RESPOND A COUPLE COMMENTS --
THE FIRST BEING THAT ARE WITH
REGARD TO NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION SAID THIS WAS A
CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED PEACE
REGARDING WHETHER EMPLOYEES
WOULD BE GIVEN RELEASE TIME TO
PARTICIPATE IN NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATIONS ARE NOT. TO SERVICE
UNITS REPRESENTED THAT ACTUALLY
WAS NOT AGREED -- TO THAT.
WE CERTAINLY AS A UNITS TO NOT
AGREE TO A SOMETHING THAT WE
SOUGHT OUT BUT IT WAS SOMETHING
THAT MINISTRATION AT THAT TIME --
DID NOT ONE INCLUDE IN THAT
LANGUAGE SINCE THAT TIME IT IS
TRUE THAT VIRTUALLY EVERY YOU IN
UNIONIZED PUBLIC EMPLOYER
CALIFORNIA HAS AGREED TO EXACTLY
WHAT THEY'RE OBJECTING.
TO THAT EMPLOYEES CAN SERVE AS A
UNION REPRESENTATIVE AND RECEIVE
PAY DURING THAT TIME.
THE DIFFERENCES IS IN THE CUT TO
BARGAINING AGREEMENT THEY CAN
COME BACK AND TAKE THAT AWAY.
IT'S INCONSISTENT WITH THE LAW
THAT ALL HAS ALWAYS PROVIDED
WHAT CAN BE GIVEN FOR RELEASE
TIME OR NOT IN THE STATUTE.
SO THAT'S OUR CONTENTION IS THAT
WE WE'RE NOT ABLE.
TO PUT INTO THE STATUTE AT THAT
TIME WHAT WE WANTED TO SO WE
CAME BACK FOR IT IS NOT A MATTER
OF THAT WE DIDN'T GET IT THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING TABLE.
BECAUSE WE DID COME BACK AND GET
IT.
THERE ALSO A FEW ARBITRATIONS
WHERE THE EMPLOYER SOUGHT NOT TO
DO THAT OR THE ARBITRATOR RULED
THAT THEY NEEDED TO PROVIDE THE
EMPLOYEES.
THAT TIME IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT
EMPLOYEE ORIENTATION MEETING.
FOR WITH REGARD TO PREPARATION
OF FOR BARGAINING BUT IT'S NOT
ME THAT WAS A RECENT PER
DECISION DEFINING WHAT THAT
MEANS -- SO I THINK THAT THAT'S
BEEN.
BOB DEFINED IN ADMINISTRATIVE
DECISIONS BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH WHAT THE OPPOSITION ON
THAT ISSUE THANK YOU.
WITH THAT THE MEMBER LIKE CLOSE
OUT OF TAKE THAT AS AS MY
CLOTHES AND JUST RE EMPHASIZE
THAT THIS PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
UNIFORMITY SPECIFICITY AND
PARITY THAT IS MUCH NEEDED AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE MISTER
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES.
THANK WITHOUT IT AND WITH THAT I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS -- BILL FORD I
ALSO SEE THE INCONSISTENCIES AND
COLLECTOR BARGAINING THE LAWS
REGARDING RELEASE TIME HAVE
CREATED UNEQUAL GROUND AMONG
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES TO EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHTS. TO FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS.
I FEEL THIS IS A GREAT BILL LOOK
FOR TO MAKE THESE LAWS THE SAME
FOR RELEASE TIME TO PREVENT
CONFUSION AND TO HELP THE PER
WITH ADMINISTRATION OF THOSE
LAWS WITH THAT I DO HAVE AYE
RECCO.
AND I BELIEVE DO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND.
HAVE A MOTION BY WERE CERVANTES.
SECOND AB O'DONNELL WITHOUT
SENATOR LIKE CALDERON.
HE AB THREE ONE FOR THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER FONG.
FONG NO O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I A WORD OF THREE
YESES TO THOSE WILL HAVE A ROLE
OPEN AND PLACE IT ON CALL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WHO'S NOT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER MEMBER -- NOR
THE ROOMS.
WHAT DO WE DO IT IN A FILE ITEM --
SHOULD I PRESENT ONE WAS NOT IN
THE THAT WE DO HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOICE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT ON YOUR A. B. FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWO AB [inaudible]
TWO FORTY NINE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND.
THE MORNING CHAIR RIGHT REGRESA
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
TODAY YEAH I AM PRESENTING AB.
TWO FORTY NINE TO PROVIDE THE
SAME PROTECTION FOR EMPLOYEES SO
WHETHER THEY JOIN WHAT DO NOT
JOIN A UNION.
UNDER CURRENT COLD.
SPECIFICALLY -- GOVERNMENT COAL
WITH THE SECTION THREE FIVE FIVE
ZERO A PUBLIC EMPLOYEE -- SHALL
NOT DETER OR DISCOURAGE A PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WALK UP THE KINDS TO
BE OP PUBLIC EMPLOYEES SO FROM
BECOMING OR REMAINING MEMBERS SO
OFTEN EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION.
I AM CURRENTLY ON AWAY -- OFFER
ANY PROTECTIONS IN PLACE.
THAT THAT WOULD ISSUE THE
EMPLOYEES OR APPLICANTS OF FROM
ABUSE OF WHAT EMPLOYERS.
ARE DETERRING AURA DISCOURAGING
APPLICANTS SO WHAT EMPLOYEES SO
FROM NOT JOINING A UNION.
THERE STANDS OUT ON OPEN AREA OF
COLD.
THAT DOES NOT PROVIDE THE FOURTH
IS A PROTECTION.
WHETHER THE OPPOSITION.
OUT WHILE THE OPPOSITION HAS SO
INUNDATED TO MY OFFICE SO WITH
THE COURTS AND THE EMAIL SAID
EXPLAINING.
HOW THIS IS OUR ALREADY
PROTECTED UNDER COLD?
NOT ONE HAS ACTUALLY SIDED THE
COLD THOUGHT THAT PROTECTS
EMPLOYEES IN THIS ARE IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
THIS BILL. TWO AB TWO FORTY NINE
IS OUT NOT TO CREATE THE HARMFUL.
OR OUT TO FIGHT THE UNION.
BUT TO INSTEAD THAT PROVIDE THE
EQUAL PROTECTION FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO DECIDE.
EITHER WAY FOR THEMSELVES
WHETHER TO JOIN ONE NOT TO JOIN.
AB TWO FORTY NINE SIMPLY ADD
SALT TO THE APPROPRIATE AREA OF
COOL WITH THE STRICT LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE THAT THE AN APPLICANT'S
OR EMPLOYEE'S SAW RIGHT TO
CHOOSE. TO JOIN OR NOT JOIN A
UNION IS A PROTECTED THE FROM
AND PRO YOUR INFLUENCE.
THANK YOU IN WITH THAT IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
I DON'T HAVE -- ANY -- PERSON TO
TESTIFY ON THIS.
FOR AND WITH THAT SAID WE HAVE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE COM.
FOR GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MICHELLE CAST
OF THE SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION -- TO ONE IT
JUST POINT OUT THAT AN
EMPLOYEE'S DECISION TO JOIN OR
TO NOT JOIN THE UNION.
IS ALREADY PROTECTED ACTIVITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE SEVERAL STATUTES THE
EFFORT THAT A FROM THIS OVER AND
OVER.
IT SAYS THAT NEITHER A UNION NOR
AN EMPLOYER CAN INTIMIDATE
DISCRIMINATE.
WART A PERSON'S DECISION TO JOIN
OR NOT JOIN A UNION.
AN EMPLOYER CANNOT ENGAGE IN ANY
DISCRIMINATORY BEHAVIOR TOWARDS
ANY EMPLOYEE FOR JOINING OR NOT
JOINING A UNION.
SOME OF THESE LAWS THAT SAY THIS
GO BACK. FOR OVER FIFTY YEARS --
THESE LAWS HAVE BEEN INTERPRETED
BY ADMINISTRATIVE AGENCIES LIKE
PERP THE SUPREME COURT THE WELL
ESTABLISHED WHEN WE ADD --
ADDITIONAL STATUTES WITH
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE IT CHANGES
THE MEANING A WELL ESTABLISHED
LAW AND INTERPRETATIONS BY THE
SUPREME COURT.
SO WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT
THIS BILL REALLY PROVIDES
NOTHING.
BUT CONFUSION TO EXISTING LAW --
EMPLOYEES WHEN THEY GET HIRED
THEY'RE NOT AUTOMATICALLY UNION
MEMBERS THEY HAVE TO TAKE AN
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION TO BECOME A
UNION MEMBER SO AN EMPLOYER --
WHEN THEY'RE HIRING PEOPLE DON'T
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS OF
WHETHER SOME OF THE UNION MEMBER
NOT BECAUSE THEY DON'T BECOME A
UNION MEMBER UNTIL AFTER THEY
GET HIRED?
UNTIL AFTER THEY ACTUALLY SIGN A
CARD SAYING I WANT TO BE A UNION
MEMBER SO WE REALLY THINK THIS
BILL IS -- NOT ENHANCING OF
EXISTING LAW BUT INSTEAD
CONFUSING OF EXISTING LAW THANK
YOU.
IS THE CHAIR OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PRIDE ALFA BEHALF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES ALSO
IN A STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. FOR MANY
OF THE REASONS THAT WERE STATED
BY MY COLLEAGUE ARE MISCAST FOR
FROM S. YEAH YOU OF JUST WANT TO
RE EMPHASIZE THE POINT THAT THIS
BILLS UNNECESSARY CALIFORNIA LAW
ALREADY PROTECTS DECISIONS OF
EMPLOYEES WHO.
ARE ELECTED JOIN OR ITS NAME
FROM JOINING THE UNION -- THE
ATTEMPT ARE WE BELIEVE OF THIS
BILL TO PRESENT ITSELF IS
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF WORKERS
TO CHOOSE THEIR REPRESENTATION
WE UNFORTUNATELY IS A DISTORTION
OF FACTS.
OF AND YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST
CONCERNED -- AND WOULD HOPE THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE AS LEGISLATIVE
BODY ODD GIVES CRITICAL
CONSIDERATION OUGHT TO WHY THIS
BILL WILL BE BROUGHT FORWARD IN
THE HOPES THAT THIS IS NOT JUST
ANOTHER ATTEMPT TO DEMONIZED
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
LABOR MOVEMENT AS A WHOLE -- YOU
KNOW FOR FIGHTING TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS THAT WE'VE WORKED TO
OBTAIN -- THE YOU KNOW FOR THE
FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED WE CAN SEE NOR THE
MOTIVATION FOR WHY THIS BILL IS
BEING BROUGHT FOR WE'D ASK. FOR
THIS BODY TO PLEASE -- OPPOSES
PEACE LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT SAID ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
NANCY FERRIS WITH SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND REPRESENTING NINETY SIX
THOUSAND STATE EMPLOYEES UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
JUST WANT TO REITERATE WHAT.
MIGHT COLLEAGUES SAID SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS
THANK YOU THANK.
KOBE PRESIDING WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS WE WOULD CERTAINLY
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF ASKS ME IN
SCA YOU IN OUR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
MORNING MEMBERS IN CHAIRED
AMYLIN MATHIS WITH UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
REALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH US ME.
GOOD MORNING CENTER BARRERA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. SEVEN BRAMBLE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE URGE A
NO VOTE.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WERE
ALSO POST.
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS THAN A
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS.
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SENATE HEARING ON ANY QUESTION
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEN HERE IN -- SOME REMEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SIR -- IT'S A QUITE
INTERESTING THAT THE ALREADY ARE --
THERE ARE ENOUGH -- COLD AND
THAT THIS BILL WOULD CREATE THE
CONFUSION -- FROM MY OWN STUDY --
THERE ARE.
SEVERAL COLD AND THAT ARE
RELATED SPECIFICALLY.
A CORD THAT COULD FIVE OH TWO
WHO HAVE THE OUR OUR RIGHT TO
JOIN OR NOT THOUGH BUT NOT OF OF
THE FREE FORM FROM THE INFERNAL.
OUT FROM THE NEGATIVE INFLUENCE
OF FROM THE EMPLOYERS. THIRTY
FIVE OH TWO POINT ONE IS OF NO
PUNISHMENT UP FOR WORKING.
IN THE UNION BUT THE NOT THE
FREEDOM THIRTY FIVE OR SIX I IS
A YOU CANNOT THOUGHT --
INTERFERE WITH THE OF CHOICE TO
OUR JOINED BUT THAT'S NOT THE
AGAIN NOT A NEGATIVE INFLUENCE
OF THIRTY FIVE OR SIX POINT FIVE
FOR THE PROTECTS THE UNIONS ARE
AND THE ARTWORK.
NOT THE CHOICE SO YOU CAN SEE A
FROM THE COLD NOT FROM MY OWN
STUDIES THIS SYSTEM ARE A
DIFFERENCE.
MOST OF THE OPPONENT -- UP TEST
FIVE YEARS -- USUALLY -- ARE THE
MEMBERS AND ALL -- THEY ARE
TRYING.
TO DETER THE INDIVIDUAL
EMPLOYEES OF FREEDOM TO JOIN NOT
TO JOIN A SOME HOW THEY WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE A MORE.
MEMBERS JUST OBVIOUSLY I CAN SEE
THE APPOINT SELF BUT THE MY
APPEARS TO INTENDED AS SUCH
INDIVIDUAL HOURS OF FREEDOM TO
JOIN ONE NOT TO JOIN.
AMEND THIS IS SO CLEAR
COMMONSENSE BEER SO I ASKED I'VE
WORKED.
WITH THAT SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THANK YOU OFFER BRING THIS BILL
FORD.
FORTUNE THIS COMMITTEE HEARS
ISSUE THAT A VERY TECHNICAL AND
COMPLEX FOR PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT.
THE LAW MUST BE CLEAR AND NOT
CONFUSING FOR THE PUBLIC TO
UNDERSTAND INCLUDING FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL MAKES IT CONFUSING
WHEN THE LAWS ALREADY CLEAR.
AND WITH THAT SAID I'M NOT
RECOMMENDED A NO VOTE AND I
BELIEVE SECTOR THE WAS A MOTION
ON THE SECOND I BELIEVE --
MOTION BY -- THE VICE CHAIR
VOEPEL AND SAID MY MISTER FONG.
AND WITH THAT SECRETARY LIKE TO
CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWO FOUR NINE THE MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ
NOW.
RODRIGUEZ NO VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I CERVANTES COOLEY.
COOPER FONG.
FONG I O'DONNELL NO.
O'DONNELL NOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE OF THE KEEP AN OPEN WOUND
HAVE TWO YES AND TWO NO'S
[inaudible]
WITH THAT.
WOULD MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT AUTHOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
MY WORK IS.
ON ITEM NUMBER SIX A. B. THREE
EIGHTY FIVE SELECT 1%.
OF SIX THREE SIX FIVE BUT WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS.
ONLY BEGIN BY GIVING A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON THE INSPIRATION
FOR THIS BILL. FOR THE LAST FIVE
YEARS I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
HAVING MORE I'LL CHAPMAN SITTING
NEXT TO ME TO DAY.
IN MY OFFICE FIRST AS AN INTERN
AND THEN AS PART TIME STAFF OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS MY CHIEF
OF STAFF HAS BEEN WORKING
TIRELESSLY WITH THE REST OF MY
TEAM. TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE THE
STATE EMPLOYMENT PROCESS AND HE
HAS FACED MANY BEARS ALONG THE
WAY.
ECONOMY HELP MORRELL SEARCH FOR
NEW JOBS POSTED ON COLLEGE ARE
THAT COMMON A WEEKLY BASIS.
I HAVE EVEN ARRANGE FOR IS THE
AYE RECRUITMENT COORDINATOR FROM
KILEY TRY TO COME BY MY OFFICE
THIS IS MORE OUT WITH THE PLANE
FOR STATE.
POSITION.
DESPITE OUR BEST EFFORTS WE HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO MAKE SOMEONE
LIKE MORALE.
MAKE SURE THAT SOMEONE LIKE
RALLIS OF FOR THE SAME
CONSIDERATIONS AS OTHER PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT DISABLED FOR JOBS.
I KNOW FIRST HAND THAT HE IS
QUALIFIED AND WILL DO A GREAT
JOB.
THERE IS RAZA HAVE ALSO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE PROGRAM AND HOW
IT IS AND ISN'T WORKING FOR
PEOPLE WITH.
DISABILITIES.
LEAVE OR THE LIMITED EXAMINATION
APPLICATION PROGRAM IS DESIGNED
TO HELP LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH ANY TYPE OF
THIS ABILITIES.
OBTAIN STATE EMPLOYMENT.
IT TURNS OUT THAT WHILE BEFORE
ME THERE WERE OTHERS ALREADY
ASKING THAT QUESTION.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN OF
FIFTEEN THERE WAS A REPORT BY
CALLIE CHAR 50% ALL BOARD AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
MADE RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE
THE UNFORTUNATELY MANY OTHERS
AND I RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE BEEN
IGNORED.
AB THREE SIX FIVE WOULD REQUIRE
IMPLEMENTATION EVERYTHING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
QUALITY JOBS WITH BENEFITS AND A
POTENTIAL FOR PENSIONS.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE INDIVIDUALS
WHO DO NOT HAVE AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BY THE SIDE ARE
SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATING OUR
SYSTEM.
AND I WANNA MAKE SURE WE HAVE
ALL LEARN FROM OUR EXPERIENCES
OF MY RELATIVELY HELP OTHERS
LIKE HIM.
AND GIVE THEM AND THEIR FAMILY
SOME PEACE OF MIND ABOUT THEIR
FUTURE.
TAKE A MOMENT TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT THE LEE PROCESS IS LIKE FOR
OTHERS YOU DON'T HAVE AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY THE SIDE.
AND I STILL HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT FOR MORALE -- IN OVER
TWO YEARS.
AND SO TO THEY WERE HOPING TO
GIVE INDIVIDUALS LIKE MORALE AND
HIS FAMILY AND OTHER MEMBERS I
CAME IN OUR COMMUNITY I HOPE I
HOPE FOR A GOOD JOB IN A PENSION
AND BENEFITS ON THE ROAD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MORALE NOW ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE FOR HIM.
THANK YOU GOD [inaudible]
TESTING TESTING.
MY NAME IS MARA GERMAN I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT AB.
TWO FIFTY FIVE I AM CURRENTLY
EMPLOYED IN THREE PART TIME JOBS
OUR GONNA HAPPEN DATE PRO.
I WOULD HAVE TO PER WEEK ON
MONDAYS THE SUMMER.
OF CRISTINA FOR SIX YEARS.
OUR HAVE BEEN PER WEEK AROUND TO
THE PIZZA ON TUESDAYS.
TUESDAYS AND CONSERVATIVE IN
WASHINGTON FIFTH.
HOWARD ACOSTA AB T. THREE DAYS
PER WEEK FOR FIVE HOURS A DAY.
TUESDAY TO THURSDAY OR I
ORGANIZE HE IN.
CLEAN AIRING IS.
OUT THE REASON LISTEN TO HELP ME.
HELP ME GET THIS JOB.
WELL I AM GLAD TO HAVE THOSE
JOBS THAT REQUIRE A LOT OF
TRAVELING ON PUBLIC SEVENTEENTH
THING BETWEEN THEM.
IN THEY ALL PAY MINIMUM WAGE.
I WANT TO GET A JOB FOR THIS THE
STATE AS A CUSTODIAN SO THAT I
CAN HAVE A PERMANENT.
JOB WORK MORE HOURS IN.
RECEIVE BENEFITS I WANT TO WORK.
AS A CUSTODIAN WHICH I BELIEVE I
HAVE THE SKILLS FOR AND I THINK
I WOULD BE VERY GOOD AT I GIVE.
ONE THEY GET IN INCOMPLETE OR
THINK THE I WANT I HAVE
REPEATEDLY TRIED TO GET A STATE
JOB.
ONLINE IN.
WITH.
OTHER CASES OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS IN I HAD HAD THE SAME
AMERICA SEEM TO HELP ME BUT I
KEEP RUNNING INTO VARIOUS
[inaudible]
UP FRONT.
I BELIEVE THAT FICTIONALLY
PROGRAM WILL HELP ME.
WILL HELP PEOPLE LIKE ME LIKE.
LIKE ME TO GET A STATE JOB THAT
IS WHY I SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK.
HOW GOOD MORNING -- CHAIRMAN
RODRIGUEZ SEVEN MEMBERS IT
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S RALPH BLACK
CAM HERE REPRESENTING --
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
STATE EMPLOYEES WITH
DISABILITIES -- BOTH -- DR SEE
AN ACCENT OR IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB.
THREE SIXTY FIVE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND ONE AND THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED A BILL A. B. NINE TO FIVE
WHICH ESTABLISHED THE GOAL OF
HAVING CALIFORNIA BECOME A MODEL
EMPLOYER PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
THE STATE IS HISTORICALLY HAD A
TWO PRIMARY MECHANISMS TO TRY TO
PROMOTE HIRING THE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE ONE IS THE
LIMITED EXAMINATION AN
APPOINTMENT PROGRAM -- AND THE
OTHER IS A REQUIREMENT THAT.
A STATE AGENCIES SET GOALS FOR
HIRING OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES BUT DESPITE THE
EXISTENCE OF THESE.
REQUIREMENTS.
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE STILL SIGNIFICANTLY UNDER
REPRESENTED IN STATE GOVERNMENT
AND MANY AGENCIES HIRE A FEW IF
ANY PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
SO WHY IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
GARCIA MENTIONED -- IN -- TWENTY
FOURTEEN CAL H. R. DEPARTMENT OF
REHAB STATE PERSONNEL BOARD
CONVENED A TASK FORCE TO STUDY
HOW TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS IN
THESE ARE.
PROGRAMS AND IMPROVE THE HIRING
OF PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES --
BACK SAID TO MANY OTHER
DISABILITY ORGANIZATIONS WERE --
INVOLVED IN MANY HOURS OF
DISCUSSIONS IN THIS TASK FORCE.
THE REPORT WAS ISSUED IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE MADE A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS SOME PROGRESS
HAS BEEN MADE ON IMPLEMENTING
THOSE REGULATIONS ARE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT MUCH MORE
STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE.
AND A. B. THREE SIXTY FIVE WOULD
TAKE SEVERAL IMPORTANT STEPS
FORWARD IN THAT PROCESS.
FIRST OF ALL IT WOULD ASK CALLIE
CHAR TO EXPAND THE SCOPE OF THE
LEAP PROGRAM RIGHT NOW THERE ARE
ONLY NINE LEAP CLASSIFICATIONS
OUT OF TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
STATEWIDE CLASSIFICATIONS THAT
CAL H. R..
ADMINISTERS SO THAT MEANS THAT
INDIVIDUALS GOING THROUGH THE
LEAGUE PROGRAM DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY.
TO PARTICIPATE IN ALL OF THOSE
OTHER EXAMINATION PROCESS IS
THROUGH THE LEE PROGRAM.
AND SO THE BILL WOULD ASK CAL HR.
TO MOVE FORWARD ON EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM TO COVER OTHER STATEWIDE
CLASSIFICATIONS.
SECONDLY OUR CALLIE CHAR WOULD
BE ASKED TO IDENTIFY DEPARTMENTS
WITH THE LOWEST RATES OF HIRING
OF PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
TO WORK WITH THEM TO ADOPT NEW
STRATEGIES. TO IMPROVE THEIR
HIRING PRACTICES AND REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON THE RESULTS
OF THAT EFFORT.
FINALLY -- BACK IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE ADOPTED
SB SIX FORTY FOUR WHICH
ESTABLISHED AN INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES AS
PART OF THE LEAGUE PROGRAM WHERE
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO GO THROUGH.
A FORMAL EXAMINATION PROCESS ARE
ABLE TO COMPLETE AN ON THE JOB
INTERNSHIP TO QUALIFY TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN A LEAP THIS BILL WOULD EXTEND
EXT ELIMINATE THE SUNSET DATE
FOR THAT PROGRAM AND ALSO ASK
CAL HR AND OTHER AGENCIES TO
WORK WITH US ON STUDYING THE
POSSIBILITY OF EXPANDING THAT
INTERNSHIP.
OPTION TO BE AVAILABLE TO OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WITH -- MOST
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES.
SO IN ORDER TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THESE KEY ISSUES WE VERGE HERE I
VOTE ON A. B. THREE SIXTY FIVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
CINDY SMITH THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AS A
STATE AGENCY WE ARE COMMITTED TO
HIRING INDIVIDUALS DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES.
AS WELL AS WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE IMPROVEMENTS THAT NEED TO BE
MADE THE PLEA PROGRAM SOMEWHERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTION BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEN HERE IN AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ID LIKE TO CLOSE.
THIS ONE AT BANK MORALE FOR
COMING OUT ENSURING THE STORY
WITH THAT.
AND I LOOK FORWARD. FIFTY MORE
OUT FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS -- BE
ABLE.
TO DO A LOT OF TASK HERE -- IN
THE CAPITAL INFLAMMATION MORALE
AND OTHER INDIVIDUALS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO HAVE A GOOD LIFE -- AS THEY
GET INTO THAT RETIREMENT AGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITHOUT ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MORE OFFER COMING FORWARD
AND SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL.
AND WITH AUTHOR I AGREE WITH THE
GOALS OF THE BILL THAT WE SHOULD
MAKE.
MORE OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE.
IN STATE SERVICE TO INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES WHAT THE SAME
THING AS ANYONE ELSE LIKE A GOOD
JOB.
AND BEING ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THE FAMILY SO WITH THAT I
RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE AND I LIKE
TO GET A MOTION AND SECOND.
THE MOTION BY MISTER BONTA
SEKHEMRE MISTRAL DONNA.
SECRETARY LIKE CALL THE ROLL YES
AB THREE SIX FIVE MOTIONS DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ HI.
RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL.
THE BILL I CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I COOLEY.
COOPER.
COOPER IPHONE.
O'DONNELL.
RIGHT O'DONNELL AYE.
IN WILL KEEP IT ON CALL BUT WITH
MOTIONS THAT THANK YOU CAME.
THE NEXT [inaudible]
ONE DOES NOT [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
QUESTION.
ALL RIGHT NUMBER AGAIN
[inaudible]
AFTER SOME.
AND WHAT MEMBERS NUMBER QUINN
DOWN THAT THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE BOARDS.
OF CALPERS AND CAL STIRS TO
DIVEST PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT FUNDS FROM ANY
INVESTMENT VEHICLE.
ISSUED BY OWNED CONTROLLED OR
MANAGED BY THE GOVERNMENT OF
TURKEY.
THE LIQUIDATION OF INVESTMENTS
IN TURKEY IS CONTINGENT UPON THE
PASSAGE OF A FEDERAL LAW ISSUING
SANCTIONS.
AGAINST TURKEY FOR FAILING TO
RECOGNIZE THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
SO THERE IS A HIGH BAR
PROTECTING THE INVESTMENTS OF
CALIFORNIANS SET -- THIS
CONTINGENCY CLAUSE INSURERS
CALIFORNIA'S POLICY TO DIVEST
FROM TURKEY REMAINS CONSISTENT
WITH PAST INVESTMENTS FROM
FOREIGN NATIONS INCLUDING SU DON
AND IRAN.
IN THAT PURRS AND STIRS WILL NOT
DIVEST UNTIL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS TAKEN ACTION
FIRST ALSO THIS BILL INCLUDES A
PROVISION PROTECTING THE BOARDS
OF CALPERS AND CAL STIRS BY
STATING ACTIONS TAKEN. TO ALIGN
WITH THIS BILL ARE NOT REQUIRED
IF THEY VIOLATE THE BOARD'S
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITIES.
FURTHER THERE'S A PROVISION
INDEMNIFY AND THE BOARDS AND
EMPLOYEES FROM CLAIMS BROUGHT
FORTH BY ACTIONS TAKEN IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THIS BILL.
REPUBLIC OF TURKEY'S
UNWILLINGNESS TO RECOGNIZE THE
GENOCIDE AND THEIR UNRELENTING
CAMPAIGN TO DENY THE GENOCIDE
CONTINUES TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ARMENIANS.
AND OTHER ETHNIC MINORITIES WHO
SUFFERED AT THE HANDS OF THE
TURKISH OTTOMAN GOVERNMENT.
CALIFORNIA HAS CLEAR POLICY ON
THE GENOCIDE AS DEMONSTRATED BY
DECADES OF LEGISLATIVE
RESOLUTIONS AND GUBERNATORIAL
PROCLAMATIONS.
CALIFORNIANS INVESTMENT IN
TURKISH GOVERNMENT BONDS
INDIRECTLY SUBSIDIZES TURKISH
THE NILE OF THE GENOCIDE.
THIS BILL CONTINUES CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO ACT APPROPRIATELY
AGAINST COUNTRIES THAT HAVE A
RECORD OF HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AND UNDERMINE
DEMOCRACY -- WITH ME I'M JOINED
BY ME RUN TO MY CHEN WITH THE
ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA.
THANK YOU GóMEZ YOU READY.
CHAIRMAN RODRIGUEZ VICE CHAIRMAN
VOEPEL.
AND FELLOW DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT.
UP MY NAME IS MEHRAN TO MUCH AND
I SERVICE THE WESTERN REGION
DIRECTOR OF THE ARMENIAN
ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA A NATIONWIDE
NONPROFIT NONPARTISAN ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
PROMOTING PUBLIC UNDERSTANDING.
AND AWARENESS OF ARMENIAN ISSUES.
MY ORGANIZATION WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORTS ASSEMBLY BILL.
AB.
THIRTEEN TWENTY AUTHORED BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN WITH
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHORS FRIEDMAN
AND GABRIEL [inaudible]
UP.
MY ORGANIZATION AMONG ITS
EDUCATIONAL INITIATIVES OF
PRODUCES RESOURCES FOR EDUCATORS
ABOUT THE NATURE CAUSES AND
CONSEQUENCES OF THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE.
AND ON THE UNIVERSAL IMPERATIVE
OF GENOCIDE PREVENTION.
THROUGHOUT THE PAST FIVE DECADES
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AN EXAMPLE --
TO FELLOW STATES WITH RESPECT TO
THE ADOPTION OF RESOLUTIONS AND
PROCLAMATIONS COMMEMORATING THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE.
IN ADDITION TO THE PASSAGE OF
LEGISLATION MANDATING THE
TEACHING THE GENOCIDE AND
STATEWIDE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
ALONGSIDE THE HOLOCAUST.
AND OTHER MODERN.
MODERN ERA MASS ATROCITIES IN
STARK CONTRAST TO THE GOLDEN
STATE'S CLEAR POSITION ON
GENOCIDE RECOGNITION AND
EDUCATION THE TURKISH STATE
MANDATES THE TEACHING OF
GENOCIDE DENIAL IN ITS SCHOOLS
AND CONTINUES A CENTURIES OLD
POLICY OF DISCRIMINATION.
TOWARDS ARMENIANS AND OTHER
MINORITY POPULATIONS.
IN RECENT YEARS TURKEY CIVIL AND
HUMAN RIGHTS RECORD HAS BEEN
ABYSMAL.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE UNDER
ARTICLE THREE A ONE OF THE PENAL
CODE IN ARTICLE EIGHT OF THE
ANTI TERROR ACT TURKISH
JOURNALISTS ACADEMICS HUMAN
RIGHTS AND CIVIL SOCIETY
ADVOCATES.
REPRESENTATIVE IS
REPRESENTATIVES OF ITS LEGAL AND
JUDICIAL COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED AND IMPRISONED FOR
QUOTE UNQUOTE.
INSULTING PUBLIC OFFICIALS OR
QUOTE UNQUOTE CARRYING OUT
CRIMES AGAINST THE STATE.
MEMBERS OF TURKEY'S MINORITY
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING KURDS A
LEVEES ARMENIANS ASSYRIANS AND
GREEKS HAVE ESPECIALLY BEEN
TARGETED FOR ARREST AND
IMPRISONMENT UNDER ARTICLE EIGHT
AND THREE OH ONE IN ADDITION
ACCORDING TO THE COMMITTEE TO
PROTECT JOURNALISTS FOR THE
THIRD STRAIGHT YEAR TURKEY
MAINTAINS.
ITS IGNOMINIOUS DISTINCTION AS
THE WORST TAYLOR OF JOURNALISTS
AND THE TO GUN REGIME REGULARLY
REFERS TO IMPRISON JOURNALISTS
AT LEAST SIXTY EIGHT ACCORDING
TO THE COMMITTEE. TO PROTECT
JOURNALISTS AS QUOTE UNQUOTE
TERRORIST CHILD MOLESTERS AND
MURDERS.
TURNING TO CRITICAL REGIONAL
ISSUES CONTRARY TO PRESIDENT
ADVANCE BEEN TRICKY HAS NEITHER
ACTED AS A GOOD FAITH PARTNER
THE GLOBAL COALITION TO DEGRADE
AND DEFEAT ISIS NOR HAS MADE
STRIDES TO MITIGATE.
THE SCOURGE OF TERRORISM AND
ISLAMIC EXTREMISM IN THE GREATER
MIDDLE EAST ACCORDING TO DAVID
PHILLIPS DIRECTOR THE PEACE
BUILDING AND HUMAN RIGHTS
PROGRAM AT COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY.
THE TICKET STATE HAS MATERIALLY
AIDED AND ABETTED ISIS.
AS WELL AS THE AL QAEDA IN THE
LABATT AND OTHER TERRORIST
ORGANIZATIONS WREAKING HAVOC IN
SYRIA AND EIGHT ANY ROCK.
PHILLIPS COLLECTED EVIDENCE OF
ANKARA'S DIRECT INVOLVEMENT IN
THE OIL TRADE WITH ISIS ITS
COMPLICITY IN ALLOWING
TERRORISTS TO TRAVERSE INTO
SYRIA AND IRAQ FROM TURKEY.
AND ITS PROVISION OF OFFENSIVE
WEAPONS MILITARY MATERIAL AND
MEDICAL ATTENTION TO MEMBERS OF
VARIOUS TERRORIST GROUPS.
TURKEY'S REPRESSION TOWARDS ITS
KURDISH MINORITY AND VIOLATIONS
OF ITS NEIGHBORS TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY HAVE EXACERBATED
TENSIONS IN THE REGION AND
HEIGHTEN THE LEVEL OF RISK. FOR
FOREIGN DIRECT INVESTMENT THE
TENUOUS SECURITY SITUATION HAS
HAD A DELETERIOUS EFFECT ON THE
TURKISH ECONOMY WITH MOODY'S
INVESTORS SERVICE RECENTLY
RATING TURKEY S. BE A THREE
NEGATIVE THREE NOTCHES BELOW
INVESTMENT GRADE.
AND FITCH RATINGS ISSUING GET BB
NEGATIVE RATING OF TURKEY TWO
NOTCHES BELOW INVESTMENT GRADE.
RISING INFLATION IN TURKEY
HOVERING AROUND 19220% IN MARCH
TWENTY NINETEEN COUPLED WITH
RAMPANT UNEMPLOYMENT A
SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN THE VALUE
OF THE TURKISH LIRA AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES DOLLAR AND THE
EURO.
SHOULD BE FACTORED INTO THE RISK
ANALYSIS OF INVESTING IN TURKISH
GOVERNMENT ISSUED AND CONTROLLED
THAT SECURITIES AND BONDS.
DESPITE THE HIGH RISK INVESTMENT
SITUATION ON THE GROUND IN
TURKEY CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS CALPERS AND
CAL STIRS JOINTLY HOLD DEBT
SECURITIES ISSUED BY THE
GOVERNMENT OF TURKEY.
IN EXCESS OF THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THE MARKET VALUE
OF WHICH HAS EXPONENTIALLY
SHRUNK OVER THE PAST YEAR IT WAS.
VALUED AT ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION LAST YEAR.
NEVER THE LESS SUCH LARGE SCALE
INVESTMENTS INDIRECTLY EIGHT IN
A BET ON CARESS STATE SPONSORED
POLICY TO DENY THE ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE AND REPRESSED
VULNERABLE CITIZENS TODAY.
THE PURPOSE OF AB THREE THIRTY
TWENTY IS TO CRAFT A SENSIBLE
POLICY WHICH REFRAINS FROM
FINANCIALLY REWARDING AND
INVESTING IN FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS.
THAT UNDERMINE DEMOCRACY AND
TRAMPLE UPON THE BASIC HUMAN AND
CIVIL RIGHTS OF ITS CITIZENS THE
APPROVAL OF THIS BILL WOULD SEND
A CLEAR SIGNAL TO RESIDENTS OF
THE GOLDEN STATE.
THAT CALIFORNIA VALUES
INVESTMENT OPTIONS THAT ARE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH ITS LEGISLATIVE
POLICIES AND PRINCIPLES IN
PROTECTING IN UPHOLDING
UNIVERSAL HUMAN AND CIVIL RIGHTS
THE RULE OF LAW.
AND THE FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION
WITHIN THE STATE AND THROUGHOUT
THE GLOBE.
INDEED AS THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY CALIFORNIA
DEMONSTRATES AN EXAMPLE
HISTORICAL RECORD OF LEADING THE
WAY IN THE ADOPTION OF
DIVESTMENT LEGISLATION.
THE SOLID PRESIDENTIAL RECORD
INCLUDES THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURES DIVESTMENT FROM
SOUTH AFRICA SPEARHEADED BY THEN
GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN INSIDE
SLIGHTLY PRIOR TO THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS.
OWN DIVESTMENT LEGISLATION VIS A
VIS SOUTH AFRICA FOR THE
LATTER'S POLICY OF APARTHEID.
AND AS A ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS ARE
YOU MENTIONED THERE'S ALSO
PRESIDENT OF FOR DIVESTING FROM
SIT DOWN AND ALSO FROM IRAN.
THE ARMENIAN SO WE AMERICA
BELIEVES THE AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
OFFERS ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS
WHICH HOLE PRESENT FORMER IN
FUTURE BOARD MEMBERS OFFICERS
EMPLOYEES AND THIRD PARTY
INVESTMENT MANAGERS HARMLESS
FROM A FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE.
IN ADDITION WE SUPPORT MEASURES
SUCH AS A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
WHICH INCLUDE SAFEGUARDS TO
MINIMIZE ANY POTENTIAL IMPACT
UPON EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES.
FINALLY SINCE THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF CASTERS IN NINETEEN THIRTEEN
AND CALPERS IN NINETEEN THIRTY
TWO THOUSANDS OF ARMENIAN
AMERICAN RETIREES IN CALIFORNIA
SPANNING BOTH PENSION SYSTEMS
INCLUDING EDUCATORSENGINEERS
ECONOMIST CIVIL SERVANTS.
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM THEIR AND
THEIR EMPLOYERS RESPECTIVE
CONTRIBUTIONS THE BOAT SYSTEMS
ARMENIAN AMERICAN RETIREES IN
CALIFORNIA MAKE UP A SIGNIFICANT
CONSTITUENCY OF THE STORIED
HISTORIES OF CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO.
I REITERATE MY ORGANIZATIONS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTEEN
TWENTY AND ASK FOR AN ABLE I
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH THAT ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
SEEN ON ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE COMPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS TING
HUTCHINGS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- REGRETFULLY
OPPOSITION OF A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY I WANT TO CLEAR THAT WE
DO NOT OPPOSE -- YOU KNOW WHAT
THE WHAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO
IT TO DO WITH REGARDS TO THE
MORAL IS SYMBOLIC IN NATURE OF
OF THE POLICY -- BUT WE SIMPLY
HAVE TO OPPOSE ANY MEASURE THAT
PUTS IN JEOPARDY WHAT WE BELIEVE
THAT WE WE BELIEVE THAT PUTS IN
JEOPARDY ABOUT THE ONE POINT
NINE MILLION.
ACTIVE OR RETIRED EMPLOYEES IN
THE CáC CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
SIMPLY PUT DIVESTMENT DOESN'T
WORK WE ARE YOU ARE TAKING AND
AN ASSET OF VALUE YOU ARE
SELLING IT -- TO TO A NON -- WHO
I I KIND OF DOUBLES A NON
CONSCIENTIOUS CONSCIENTIOUS AND
MASTER -- AND THAT THAT IT WAS
NO CHANGE IN CONTRAST WHEN WHEN --
CALPERS SHOWING DATING GAUGE
WITH WITH STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE
HAVE SEEN CHANGE FOR EXAMPLE.
THERE WERE -- MEASURES LAST YEAR
THAT WOULD MANDATED THE FIND I.
BASS FROM -- RETAILERS WHO SELL
HIGH POWERED FIREARMS -- THE
BILL FORTUNATELY DID NOT MOVE I
CALPERS DIE IN GAUGE WITH THOSE
RETAILERS AND WE'VE SEEN AT
RECENTLY THAT DICK'S SPORTING
GOODS HAS NO LONGER DECIDE TO
SELL HIGH POWERED FIREARMS IT'S
WORKING WHEN WE ENGAGE USING OUR
PROXY VOTING -- WORK WORKING
WITH THESE COMPANIES -- BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT THAT'S AND DOESN'T
WORK ENGAGEMENT DOES WORK WE
COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
THERE REALLY IS NO MORAL VICTORY
WITH RETIREMENT SECURITY -- THE
THE CHALLENGE WITH THE THE
ONSLAUGHT OF THE DIVESTMENT
BILLS IS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
TAKE AWAY THE TOOLS THAT THE
INVESTMENT TEAM NEEDS.
BY.
ABOUT THE SAME TIME KICKING THEM
FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO MEET THEIR
BEST RETURNS AND WHILE THERE IS
LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT SAYS THEY
HAVE TO CITE THE PURDUE SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY.
FISHER RESPONSIBILITIES VERY --
AT UP FOR INTERPRETATION THE
CALPERS BOARD -- USED THEIR
PRODUCE YOUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
DIVEST FROM THE TOBACCO INDUSTRY --
THAT'S ALL FINE AND GOOD EXCEPT
FOR ITS COST THE FUND ABOUT TEN
TO TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
POTENTIAL LOSSES.
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR SUCH WAS
BECAUSE THERE WAS LAWSUIT THAT
WERE PENDING AGAINST TOBACCO
COMPANIES THERE FOR THE SHARES
COULD BE GOING DOWN.
USING THEIR PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY THERE INDEMNIFIED
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
INDEMNIFIED ARE THE ACTIVE
EMPLOYEES RETIREES IN THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE THE INSURERS
OF ANY LOSS THAT THE DIVESTMENT
DOES CREATE.
THE THE FIND IS THAT 65% FUNDED
THAT IS SIXTY FIVE CENTS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR THAT AS TO AN
ACTIVE OR RETIRED EMPLOYEE.
THE FIGHT DE THE PERSPECTIVE
RETURNS FOR THIS YEAR BOB WILL
LIKELY NOT HIT THE 7% MARK.
THAT IS ANOTHER THAT IS YET
GOING TO BE YET ANOTHER --
STOPGAP WERE EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES
AND RETIREES HAVE TO MAKE UP
THAT DIFFERENCE -- THE NUMBERS
WE'VE SEEN HOVER AROUND FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
DOES NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT --
THAT.
THE CALPERS STAFF AND CAL STAR
STAFF HAVE TO NOW GO THROUGH AND
SEEK OUT INDIVIDUALS SPECIALIZE
INDEX FUNDS GO THROUGH AND MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY SINGLE INDEX
FUNDED THERE THAT THEY'RE
INVESTING AND DOES NOT HAVE ITS
HOLDINGS.
OTHERS FEES ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
AS WELL -- WEEK COMPLETELY GET
AND UNDERSTAND -- THE THE
MOTIVATION FOR THIS -- BUT
DIVESTMENT AS A PRINCIPAL WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED WE SIMPLY
CANNOT SUPPORT A MEASURE THAT
PUTS AT RISK THE MILLIONS OF
ACTIVE AND RETIRED A PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES WHO DEPEND.
ON THEIR PENSIONS -- MOVING FORT
SO I WITH THAT RESPECT THE
OPPOSE -- ANYONE ELSE IN A CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DEAL
GIVENS WITH CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION LIKE TO
APPLY MY COMMENTS WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES -- A A GET A
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON A VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC -- POWER WITH
REGARD TO DIVEST SPENT.
WE AT THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE VESTMENT
IS A SOUND INVESTMENT POLICY --
AND WE ARE -- A GRATEFUL FOR THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS APPRECIATION OF
OUR POSITION ON THIS.
HE'S BEEN VERY UNDERSTANDING
BECAUSE THIS IS A A VERY
SENSITIVE TOPIC -- HOWEVER WHEN
IT WHEN IT COMES -- TO CALPERS
INVESTMENT POLICIES WE BELIEVE
AS THE LEAGUE SAID THAT WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THE INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AT CALPERS TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF THE FUND --
REMAIN OPEN TO THE TO THE STAFF
THERE CALPERS AND WE DON'T TIE
THEIR HANDS AND AN ADVERT LEE.
COST.
THE RETIREES AND THEIR PENSIONS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE POSTED
THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHOICE WHEN MARTINEZ WAY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
THE DALLAS IS WE APPRECIATE
RAISES MANY OF CASTERS CONCERNS
THINK.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING ON ANY
QUESTION BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
BY CHERYL PEARL.
MORE OF A COMMENT ON GENERALLY I
AGREE WITH LEE GET CITIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
ABOUT TO BURST MEN AND
MICROMANAGING THE INVESTMENTS
OKAY SO I GET IT.
I'M A FINANCIAL GUY.
IN THE CASE OF TURKEY THOUGH.
IS BEN EGREGIOUS.
TURKEY'S TREATMENT OF COURSE OF
THE ARMENIANS IN THE PAST BUT
CURRENTLY THE KURDS.
AND UNDER THE PRESIDENT OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THEY DID NOT
COOPERATE WITH THE UNITED STATES
EFFORTS IN.
COMBAT IN ISIS.
ALSO THEY WERE [inaudible]
IT'S PROVEN.
WORKING TO SELL OIL ON BEHALF OF
ISIS.
SO [inaudible]
BAD PLAYERS.
BAD DOG BED DOG.
SO WHAT I'M GOOD AT SUPPORT THIS.
SIMPLY OUT OF HISTORICAL.
FAIRNESS.
AND THE CURRENT STATE OF
TURKEY'S RELATIONS WITH THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
I HAVE NO FAITH IN TURKEY BE IN
ANY KIND OF AN ALLY EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE A NATO ALLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR.
ANYONE ELSE ANY QUESTIONS
WITHOUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIKE
CLOTHES.
SURE THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL I
DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THE
DETAILS OF RESPONDING BECAUSE I
THINK WE'VE GONE BACK AND FORTH
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST FIVE
YEARS.
OF ON THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE AND IT
SEEMS LIKE THE THE THE
OPPOSITION HAS CHANGED -- AMONG
A VARIETY OF ACTUALLY FRIENDS
AND INDIVIDUALS THAT I'VE WORKED
WITH CLOSELY ON OTHER ISSUE
AREAS -- BUT WHEN -- THE
OPPOSITION OF SOME OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WERE REMOVED OR
WENT TO WATCH -- OR FORMAL
OPPOSITION WAS AND PUT INTO
PLACE ANOTHER ORGANIZATION
STEPPED INSULT LEAVE IT AT THAT --
I UNDERSTAND THAT THESE ISSUES
SET.
THE POTENTIAL OF A PRECEDENCE
THAT WE DO NOT WANT I RESPECT
THAT.
THAT'S WHY.
I'VE TAKEN ALL THE AMENDMENTS
AND ALL THE PROTECTIONS
NECESSARY. TO FIRST GIVE YOU A
SENSE SENSE OF COMFORT MISTER
CHAIR AS WELL AS HE COMMITTEE --
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ENSURING THAT THERE
IS.
NOTHING THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
THAT'S GONNA COMPROMISE OR
JEOPARDIZE THE INVESTMENTS OF
OUR PENSIONERS I AM VERY
SENSITIVE TO THAT -- I WANT TO
SEE A THRIVING CALIFORNIA WITH
THE PENSIONERS WERE GOING TO
CONTINUE SPENDING THEIR HARD
EARNED MONEY.
IN THE FUTURE -- SO THAT OUR
LOCAL BUSINESSES STAY EMPLOYED
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED SO THERE'S NO
ISSUE OVER THIS.
AND I THINK THE MORE WE BRING
THAT UP.
THE MORE WE REALLY.
NOT ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO BE
TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN YOU SEE A ERADICATION OF A
CELL OF CIVILIZATION?
IN A PLACE WHERE THEY USED TO
HAVE HISTORICAL MONUMENTS.
WHEN SEVENTEEN HUNDRED FIFTEEN
HUNDRED YEAR OLD CHURCHES?
ARE NOW [inaudible]
DECIMATED.
WHEN THE CROSS STONE'S THAT
THERE ARE I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
THROUGHOUT?
DISPERSED THROUGHOUT WEST
EASTERN TURKEY FORMER WESTERN
ARMENIA.
ARE NOW BEING VIDEOED.
CURRENTLY.
THAT THEY ARE BEING DESTROYED
AND CRUMBLED SO THAT.
THERE IS A COMPLETE.
A RESERVE OF OF OF ANY
HISTORICAL CONTEXT OF THE PEOPLE
THAT LIVED.
IN A CERTAIN PLACE.
WHAT WHAT I'M FRIGHTENED BY IS
THAT WHEN WE DON'T STAND TO
CORRECT THAT [inaudible]
WHEN IS?
IT'S HUMAN NATURE.
SOME DAY SOMETHING IS GOING TO
CATCH UP WITH US.
AND SO I I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY.
OF WE SOMETIMES ARGUE CERTAIN
FIGHT OR MAKE CERTAIN ARGUMENTS
WHEN WE DON'T WANT TO SEE.
THAT THERE'S A MORAL OBLIGATION
TO STAND BY.
WHEN WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING TO
PROTECT?
THE VERY INTERESTS OF THOSE THAT
WE REPRESENT TODAY.
WE'VE DONE THAT.
THIS BILL PROTECTS CALIFORNIA
PENSIONERS -- SO I AREA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE WITH ME. TO GET THIS
BILL TO THIS PLACE.
THANK YOU AND WITHOUT ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD.
A STATE REFORM I RESPECT THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU'RE REYES
REGARDING THE AMERICAN.
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE AND THE
GOVERNMENT OF TURKEY.
WELL I STILL SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL AND USING PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT MONIES TO
ACHIEVE.
WHAT I THINK IS A SYMBOLIC GO
YOU ACCEPTED ALL THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE BETTER
PROTECTIONS?
I LOOK FOR TO SUPPORTING THIS
BILL SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
SEE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND MOVE THE VEIL.
OF A MOTION AS AMENDED MOTION
AND A SECOND.
WITH THAT SECTOR LIKE CALDERON
ALL RIGHT AB THIRTEEN TWENTY DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ.
VEGAS I WILL TELL.
LOCAL I. CERVANTES. SEVEN TO SAY.
AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER FONG
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
IN SLOW.
THAT MEASURES OUT FOR WAS TO
KEEP IT ON THE ROLE OF AN UNCLE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
IS.
ON HIS WAY TO AN OKAY.
THE REASON OF MY I THINK YOU'RE
TRYING TO HOLD IT ON ONE OF THE
THREE YES HIS BILL.
YEAH.
HE DOES WERE SPOT ON OKAY.
THE VICE CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
A GORDON PRESENT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY WOULD LIKE
TO PRESENT.
WILL BE VISITING ON ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB -- THREE FIFTY FIVE WHEN
YOU'RE READY SIR GOING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WAS
NEXT DOOR AT THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE AND WE JUST FINISHED
UP -- CURRENTLY ALL BUT FOURTEEN
OF CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES ARE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD.
ALSO KNOWN AS PER BY P. E. R. B..
PUBLIC AGENCIES NOT COVERED BY
PER LABOR DISPUTES ARE OFTEN
CONTESTED IN THE COURT ROOM
WHICH CAN BE COSTLY AND TIME
CONSUMING.
BY CONTRAST BURBS EXPERTISE IN
LABOR RELATIONS LAW OFFERS
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES AN
EXPEDITIOUS AND COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVE TO ADJUDICATING
WORKPLACE DISPUTES.
THIS BILL SIMPLY ADDS THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
TO THE LIST OF PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES.
ALREADY COVERED UNDER PER.
WITH ME TODAY SHANE GROSSMAN
REPRESENTING THE TEAMSTERS WHO
WILL SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE MEMBERS
AT ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY PROXIMALLY ABOUT --
NINE HUNDRED I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE IDEA OF A COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVE TO GOING TO COURT.
AS YOU KNOW ALL THE CUTS TO THE
COURTS OVER -- THE RECENT
DECADES HAVE PRETTY MUCH
DECIMATED THE ABILITY FOR SO
CIVILLITIGANTS TO GET A QUICK.
AND SPEEDY -- DECISION ON THEIR
DISPUTES -- PER -- WILL PROVIDE
THAT FOR FOLKS AYE I KNOW THERE
HAS BEEN A HISTORIC BACKLOG AT
PER BUT WITH SOME RECENT BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS THEY'VE BEEN ABLE
TO HIRE -- STAFF AND AND RESOLVE
THAT ISSUE TO A CERTAIN DEGREE
AND REGARDLESS IT'S FASTER THAN
COURT SO -- WITH THAT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL YEAH WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO YOUR
SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE'S BORDERS MEASURE.
SAME HERE KNOWN ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
SEEING NONE -- ANY.
QUESTION BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WITHOUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEES -- ANALYSIS AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS UP
BILL FORD I DO HAVE AN IRAQ ON
THIS SO SECRETARY LIKE CHOLERA.
AB THREE FIFTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
RODRIGUEZ HI MY VEGAS AYE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
CERVANTES.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
I O'DONNELL.
GUS SO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN AND
NEED ONE MORE VOTE TO GET OUT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THERE.
WITHOUT THE LIKE REPORT ARE PER
THE AUTHOR ON A OF FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN A. B..
THREE SEVEN TWO VOEPEL HE HAS
PULLED THE HIS ITEM THAT
SCHEDULED TO BE HEARD TODAY SO
WILL NOT BE HEARING.
ONCE AGAIN ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
THREE SEVEN DUE TO PER AUTHORS
QUEST.
SO WITH THAT [inaudible]
IF [inaudible]
SOMEONE [inaudible]
AUSTRIA -- YES OF COURSE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER YOU'D LIKE
TO REPRESENTS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WITH THAT WE HAVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB TEN THIRTY
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
OF AND HE HAS A FARM NUMBER
THREE A. B..
TWO SIX SEVEN ONE OF SELECT ONE
FILE ITEM PRESENT THE FIRST.
ONE AT TWO THIRTY ONE CORRECT
YES THANK YOU FOR YOUR THREE
THANK YOU GRETA.
MISSED YOUR MEMBERS AB TWO
SEVENTY ONE WILL HELP CLOSE THE
GENDER AND ETHNICITY PAY GAP.
IN THE UP UNDER REPRESENTATION
OF WOMEN AND MINORITIES AND
STATE CIVIL SERVICE
CLASSIFICATIONS.
THIS THE THIRD BILL I'VE OFFERED
TO ADDRESS PAY EQUITY.
HOWEVER RACIAL ETHNIC
DISPARITIES REMAIN AN ISSUE
TWENTY FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA WOMEN
EARNED. EIGHTY FOUR CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR COMPARED TO MEN THIS
RESULT IN A THIRTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR LOST ANNUAL INCOME.
THIS PILLSBURY IMPACTS NOT JUST
WOMEN'S DALY LIES BUT ALSO THE
RETIREMENT.
A TWENTY SIX REPORT FROM -- CAL
HR FOUND THAT WOMEN STATE
WORKFORCE -- ABOUT SEVEN NINE
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR COMPARED TO
MEN.
AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN WILL REQUIRE
THE STATE AGENCY DEPARTMENTS TO
REPAIR A DETAILED REPORT ON
GENDER ETHNICITY WAGE DISPARITY.
AND OTHER REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES.
EACH DEPARTMENT PLANTS REPORT
ANNUALLY TO THE APPROPRIATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AND MUST
INCLUDE INFORMATION REGARDING
THE STATE AGENCIES PROGRESS.
NAY DETAIL TIMELINE FOR ME THE
GOAL OF WAGES PREPARED IN
RECRUITING.
ATTRACTING RETAINING WOMEN AND
MINORITIES MEMBERS THIS BILL
WILL HOLD A PUBLIC IT'S THE KIND
OF ALL NATURE THAT REAL PROGRESS
IS BEING MADE TOWARDS CLOSING
THE PAY GAP -- STEFFI A THREE
AYE VOTE.
ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT AND HAVE A
COUPLE WITNESSES.
WITH THE CHAIR MEMBERS A
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW FROM FROM
THE AMERICAN STE -- FEDERATION
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
I HEAR STRONG SUPPORTERS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION HI THIS IS -- I
BELIEVE A VALIANT EFFORT BY THE
AUTHOR TO BRING FORWARD A A
MEANS BY WHICH TO DO A PROPER
EVALUATION -- OF WASTE A
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST
PARTICULARLY TALK ABOUT MISTAKES
SERVICE -- OVER THE A COUPLE OF
DECADES AGO THIS BODY RECOGNIZE
THE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT -- IN
STATUTE -- UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THE LEGISLATION --
OR THAT THIS BODY HAS DONE A
COMPREHENSIVE OF EVALUATION OVER
TIME -- THIS JUST ENSURES THAT
OUR STATE.
ODD.
DOES THE WORK THAT WE HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED TO ANOTHER PIECE OF
THE LEGISLATION ENSURING THAT
PAY EQUITY EXISTS FOR ALL
WORKERS THE SERVICE REGARDLESS
OF THE CLASSIFICATION REGARDLESS
OF THE WORK THAT YOU DO -- SO
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE HERE
SUPPORTERS A VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE EMPLOYEES THAT WE
REPRESENT IN FEMALE DOMINATED
CLASSIFICATIONS WHO HAVE --
HISTORICALLY DEALT WITH THESE
TYPES OF PAY EQUITY ISSUES.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT.
LATER MOM AND WITH THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS
NOT SAY -- AB TWO SEVEN ONE GOES
A LONG WAY IN HELPING THE SOME
OF THESE PROFESSIONS THAT MAY
NOT BE FEMALE DOMINATED LIKE
WHEN WE LOOK AT PSYCHIATRY AND
PHYSICIANS SURGEONS CDC ARE.
AB TWO SEVENTY ONE CAN BE.
A GREAT HELP GOING FORWARD AND
SO WHEN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH THEIR
AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CITIES ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS IN THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL LAST YEAR WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL IT'S
INFORMATION THE STATE SHOULD
KNOW WHEN WE ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS COULD BE PROVIDED
WITH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS WE WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THAT -- OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS
IN APPS ME -- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
STRUCTURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON A BILL JOHNSON
PRESIDENT OF ASKED ME LOCAL
TWENTY SIX TWENTY REPRESENTING
OVER FIVE THOUSAND HEALTH AND
SOCIAL PER.
SOCIAL SERVICE PROFESSIONALS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA A NUMBER
OF OUR CLASSIFICATION OR SIT
SIGNIFICANTLY FEMALE DOMINATED
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT OUR BROTHERS
WITH A YES VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT SAY NONE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ANY
QUESTION BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CENA MARIE LIKE CLOSE RESPECT
YESTERDAY VOTE.
WELL THANK YOU FOR OUR BRING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL FORD I'M
AWARE OF THE ONGOING WORK BY THE
STATE'S AS RELATES TO CIVIL
SERVICE.
I BELIEVE ALSO THAT THERE MUST
BE EQUAL PAY INSTEAD EMPLOYMENT
AND THE STATE SHOULD TAKE A HARD
LOOK AT THE SOME VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES WITH THAT I DO RECOMMEND
AN AYE VOTE.
AND SECRETARY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CALL THE ROLL.
WE HAVE MOTION OTHER MOVED ON
THIS.
I'D MOTION BY HUMANS WHO LIVE IN
LAS VEGAS.
SECOND THE BILL MOTION AND
SECOND [inaudible]
THANK CALDERON.
AB TWO SEVENTY ONE THE MOST TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ
HI.
I REDUCE AYE VOEPEL.
I CERVANTES COOLEY HI.
COOLEY AYE COOPER AYE COOPER
IPHONE.
FIVE FONG AYE O'DONNELL.
AND WITH THAT THE MOTION THAT
WILL STILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FORTY MISSING MEMBERS.
SO.
SO WITH THAT -- SOME REMEMBER
YOU HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE A.
B. TEN THIRTY THREE WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
ZERO THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS ALIKE
TO ACCEPT ALL THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK
ON THIS MEASURE AB TEN THIRTY
THREE WILL ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS FOR OFFER EMPLOYMENT
BY STATE AGENCY. TO PROVIDE OF
AN EXPLANATION OF THE BENEFITS
THAT ACCOMPANIES STATES SERVICE.
WILL STIPULATE THAT THE EMPLOYEE
MUST RECEIVE A WRITTEN MEMBERS.
REALIZATION MEMORIALIZATION I'M
SORRY THE KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY
RECEIVE THESE MATERIALS BEFORE
ACCEPTING EMPLOYMENT.
THIS BILL CLARIFY IT MANDATE
THAT DEPARTMENTS PROVIDE
APPLICANTS WITH AN EXPLANATION
OF THE SALARY RANGES.
IN INTERMEDIATE STEPS WITHIN
THOSE RANGES.
IN THE BENEFITS AFFORDED THROUGH
BEING A CALPERS IN THE BENEFITS
A PROTECTIONS PROVIDE THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES BUT THE STATE'S CIVIL
SERVICE TAX.
YOU MAY MEN [inaudible] TO PASS.
THANK YOU SIR.
VIDEO.
IN WITHOUT ANY ANY OTHER MEMBERS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE
MAJOR MOM AGAIN WITH THE UNION
OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS -- SPONSOR THIS BILL --
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ANALYSIS THAT WAS DONE AND WE
AGREE THAT THIS IS REALLY JUST
CODIFICATION OF BEST PRACTICES
AND AS WE LOOK FORWARD -- TO
HIRING THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES I
BELIEVE THAT THIS GOES A LONG
WAY IN A ARE GREAT WAY AND
PUTTING OUR BEST FOOT FORWARD
AND SOME HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
WITH THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW SOME OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES ARE
PLEASED TO BE CO SPONSOR.
OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION LONG WITH OUR
AFFILIATE THE UNION OF AMERICAN
PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS SELAMA
COMMENTS WITH.
THOSE -- STATED BY MISTER
MUHAMMAD THAT THIS IS A
CODIFICATION OF UP THAT OF WHAT
WE BELIEVE TO BE A BEST PRACTICE
WHICH THIS BODY IS NOT MANY
TIMES BEFORE -- AND THINK THAT
THIS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
CLASSIFICATION OF WORKERS THAT
WERE HIRING IN A IN STATE
SERVICE ARE PARTICULARLY THOSE
AND AREAS A HIGH VACANCY RATES --
BUT IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE FOLKS.
HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT THEIR BENEFITS PACKAGES AND
WHAT THEY'RE BOB IS THE TOTAL.
OF PACKAGES WHEN THEY'RE COMING
AT ENTERING INTO STATE SERVICE
SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST NOT VOTE.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SHE CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AGAIN
ABDEL JOHNSON WITHOUT SOME LOCAL
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ON THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT BILLS SPECIALLY FOR
FOLKS IN STATE SERVICE THAT --
WHEN THERE ARE HOLES AND GAPS IN
TERMS OF INFORMATION THAT'S
BEING DELIVERED TO OUR MEMBERS?
ONCE ONE OF OUR MEMBERS FINDS
OUT ABOUT IT -- THERE'S NOT THE
ONLY OPTION IS TO GRIEVE -- AND
IT'S WERE ASKING OUR EMPLOYEES
TO GRIEVE WHILE THEY'RE ON
PROBATION WHICH PUTS THEM IN A
TERRIBLE SITUATION SO WE
DEFINITELY STAND IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS KOBE PRESIDED WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS FOR ALL
THE REASONS STATED WE WOULD
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
WHICH CHEN MEMBERS PATRON WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORTERS MEASURE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
ANY QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
TING HEARING NONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
IN WITH THAT SAID I JUST BEEN --
REMINDED BY A STAFF THAT THERE
WERE NO PROPOSED AMENDMENTS I
THINK WE'RE GONNA MOTIONS TO
PASS THAT AS IT IS SO WITH THAT --
SECRETARY WOULD YOU LIKE
CALDERON WE HAD TO HAVE A MOTION
BY SOME RECALLING.
THE SECOND BY THE WAY WISEMAN
THE FONG THANK YOU WITH THAT.
WHEN CALDERON?
AB TEN THIRTY THREE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ HI.
OUR VEGAS AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL EYES CERVANTES COOLEY.
COOLEY COOPER HI COOPER I FONG.
FONG I O'DONNELL.
THE MEASURES OUT WORSE KEEP THE
ROLE LOOKING FOR MISSING MEMBERS.
SO NOW I HAVE OF MY TO TO WHICH
IS THE FIRST
[inaudible]
ONE EIGHTY ONE YEAH YOUR
REMEMBER TO DO THIS.
YOU GOT GOOD CODE.
OKAY.
SO WHERE IS THE GO.
WHICH OF THE FOR SOMEONE ANYONE.
WHICH CORNROW FILE ITEM.
ITEM ONE EIGHTY ONE MISTER
RODRIGUEZ YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB.
ONE EIGHTY ONE UNTIL LAST YEAR
CALPERS MCALISTER'S REQUIRED
PROVIDE A FIVE YEAR STRATEGIC
PLAN FOR MERGING MANAGER
PARTICIPATION.
ACROSS ALL ASSET CLASSES OF
THEIR INVESTMENTS AND TO SUBMIT
AN ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING THE
PROGRESS OF THEIR STRATEGIC
PLANS ALTHOUGH CALPERS AND CAL
STAR SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR.
DOT LAW SUNSET ON JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS BILL SIMPLY
PLACE BACK IN THE LAW REQUIRED
AND REPORTS TO THE LEGISLATURE
REGARDING.
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS USE OF
EMERGING AND TRANSITIONAL
MANAGER FOR PURPOSES OF A SET
ASSET MANAGEMENT.
THIS BILL SIMPLE THAT WILL SHED
MORE LIGHT ON THE DIVERSITY
INVESTMENT OF OUR SYSTEM
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL GET
BEHIND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CHOICE ON MARTINEZ
WEIGHT WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN
SUPPORT WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU.
A GOOD MORNING -- DANNY BROWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALPERS BOARD OF
ADMINISTRATION AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO AN INVESTMENT
STRATEGY THAT DOES INCLUDE
EMERGING MANAGER SO WE ARE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
I'M I MAKE A MOTION THE BILL
COLLECTOR FOR COMMENT CONCERNING
IT.
I JUST WANT OBSERVE THAT THE
EMERGENCY IN EMERGING MANAGERS
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT THIS ROUND
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST THE PEOPLE
TALENT WHICH REPRESENTS.
DIVERSITY AND DIVERSE SKILL SETS.
BUT ACTUALLY IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY THE VERY NATURE OF
INVESTMENTS IN CHANGES BECOMING
MORE COMPLICATED THERE'S NEW
ASSET CLASSES.
AND SO I THINK TO GET A WIDE
ARRAY OF PEOPLE.
WHO ARE DEVELOPING A SKILL SET
AS A AS A MANAGER BUT ALSO
GAINING FAMILIARITY WITH THE
VERY DIVERSE? SEVEN WHICH
INVESTMENTS NEED TO BE MADE TO
BE COMPATIBLE TO STAY IN THESE.
I THINK IT'S IT'S MORE THAN JUST
THE PEOPLE EQUATION BUT IT'S AN
EMERGING MANNER.
MANAGER THIS BECOME FAMILIAR
WITH EMERGING ASSET CLASSES SO I
THINK TO BE VERY INTENTIONAL
ABOUT DEVELOPING THIS SKILL IS
IS VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT'S
ACTUALLY QUITE COMPLICATED SOY.
DELIGHTED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE.
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING.
NOTHING THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
PROJECT LAST RIVAL THANK YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SECOND.
THE WE MADE A MOTION.
WE NEED A SECOND [inaudible]
SECOND.
THIS AUDIT WITH THE FEC SO A
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTY ONE
EIGHTY ONE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ.
AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE VOEPEL.
WELL I CERVANTES [inaudible]
COOLEY HI.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE FUNK [inaudible]
I O'DONNELL [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I WE KEEP.
YOUR BILL IS OUT AND WE'LL KEEP
IT ON CALL.
ITEM EIGHT A. B. FOR SIXTY TWO
LISTS ABOUT RODRIGUEZ.
TURN MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
A BEFORE.
SIXTY TWO THIS BILL SIMPLY MAKES
A MINOR CHANGE IN THE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT LAW AND REMOVES
REFERENCES TO GENDER FOR
PURPOSES OF CONFORMITY TO OTHER
PROVISIONS IN THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES.
RETIREMENT LAW ADMINISTRATIVE BY
CASTERS AND CALPERS RESPECTFULLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU. TO HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
SECOND IS ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE MAJOR.
OPPOSITION TO THE MAJOR.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WELL.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE PLEASE.
OUR CIGARETTES PRIVATE.
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
SECOND.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOR SIXTY TWO DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RODRIGUEZ HI OUR
VEGAS AYE VOEPEL I VOEPEL AYE
CERVANTES.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
PHONE I O'DONNELL.
HI.
LE PASSES OUT WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR LATE POSTS [inaudible]
YEAH.
I COULD DO IT LATER [inaudible]
JOHN [inaudible]
GOOD [inaudible]
YES.
SO YOU CAN CALL THE REMAINS OF
THE MISSING MEMBERS WE CAN --
LOOK THE CALL ON THE ITEMS THAT
WE DO.
I DON'T PLAY [inaudible]
YES [inaudible] FOR WAS I HERE
[inaudible]
CHAU.
ALL THE DIFFERENT THINGS.
THAT I DIDN'T.
WE CAN WE ARE MISSING.
YEAH [inaudible]
THAT NUMBER.
WITHOUT SECRETARY LIKE TO CALL
THE ROLL MISSING MEMBERS ON THAT
OPTION OF THE RULES.
WHO WAS A MISSING MEMBERS?
RULES -- CERVANTES.
AND COOPER HI.
SO WAS PHONE.
IN WITHOUT TO GO AHEAD AND FILE
ITEM.
THE FIRST ONE FILE ITEM ONE AB.
ONE EIGHTY ONE THE MISSING
MEMBERS.
WITHOUT WILL MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB [inaudible]
TWO FORTY NINE THE WELL SO KEEP
THAT THE ROLL OPEN FOR A MISSING
NUMBER.
THE BILL IS OUT THERE.
PHONE NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO FORTY
NINE CHOI CALLED THE MISSNG
MEMBERS. FORTY NINE MISSING
MEMBERS CERVANTES [inaudible]
COOLEY NOW.
COOLEY MAIL COOPER [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
COOPER NO. SEVEN TO EIGHTY TWO
FORTY NINE YEAH.
THAT MEASURE FAILS. TO YES IS
FIVE KNOWS.
AND WITHOUT TO FOLLOW NUMBER
THREE AB TWO SEVEN ONE COOPER.
CALLED THE MISSING MEMBERS.
AB TWO SEVENTY ONE CERVANTES HI.
CERVANTES I AND O'DONNELL ARE
O'DONNELL.
THE BILL IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO NEXT FALL UNDER
NUMBER FOUR A. B. THREE FOURTEEN
BONTA CALL THE MISSION MEMBERS
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
I HI.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
FIVE TWO NEXT ONE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB THREE FIFTY FIVE
DALY.
US SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS [inaudible]
I CERVANTES [inaudible]
MOUNTAINS.
O'DONNELL RIGHT.
DOWN HI.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB -- THREE SIX FIVE CALL THE
MACHINE MEMBERS [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
I COOLEY I HI.
PHONE.
AND JUST IN CASE THE MEMBERS
WERE NOT HERE FAR NUMBER SEVEN
A. B. THREE SEVEN TWO VOEPEL WAS
FOR BY THE AUTHOR WILL NOT BE
HEARING THAT TODAY.
SO NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT A. B..
FOUR SIX TWO I'M SORRY BACK TO
THE PHONE NUMBER -- FIVE THREE
FIVE FIVE THEY'LL.
THREE SIX FIVE THAT IS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO SO BACK TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB.
FOR SIXTY TWO CALLED MISS
MEMBERS CERVANTES.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
SEVEN ZERO NEXT ONE FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE A. B. FIVE TWENTY
NINE ROMMEL'S CALLS MISSING
MEMBERS.
COOLEY AYE COOPER HI COOPER AYE
FONG.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
FIVE TWO NEXT ONE IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB.
EIGHT NINETY FOUR SECRETARY
CALLED THE MISSING MEMBERS.
HI COOLEY AYE COOPER.
I FONG NO [inaudible]
PHONE NO.
THAT MEASURES OUT.
FIVE TWO ABOUT.
THIRTY THREE PHONE NUMBER TWELVE
A. B. TEN THIRTY THREE COOPER.
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS.
CERVANTES AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL ONLINE.
THAT MOTIONS OUT SEVEN ZERO NEXT
ONE FIVE NUMBER.
THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS. FOR NO O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL NO.
THE MEASURES OUT FOR THREE OF I
BELIEVE THAT'S ALL OF THEM.
I BELIEVE THE FIRST ONE PHONE
NUMBER ONE AB ONE AB ONE A
SERVICE.
BRING I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CUT
DOWN. ONE ONE WE SO SECRETARY --
OPEN THE ROLE ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB ONE AB
[inaudible]
ONE CERVANTES.
AND ALSO WILL GO BACK TO THE
RULES.
SECRETARY CALLED THE MISSING
MEMBERS ON ADOPTION OF THE RULES
[inaudible]
CERVANTES HI.
I WANT TO SIGN.
IN WITH THAT SAID I BELIEVE WE
GOT ALL OF OUR MEASURES
.
THE TWO ON EIGHT TWENTY ONE
SECOND WHICH WILL BY
[inaudible]
TWENTY NINE DOES NOT.
IN JUST FOR A CLARIFICATION ON A
FAR NUMBER NINE A. B..
FIVE TWO NINE RAMOS THAT
MEASURES OUT [inaudible] FIVE
ZERO FIVE ZERO YES.
SO WITH THAT SAID THIS CONCLUDES
OUR HEARING.
AND THANK YOU FOR JOINING.
MEASURE MEETING THE JOURNEY